hey everybody welcome to the podcast you
guys are in for a treat today because my
guest
is caroline berkel caroline is a 2012
olympian
she's a 23-time all-american
swimmer an nc2a champion an nc2a record
holder
one of my very favorite people i
absolutely adore her
this is an amazing and powerful
conversation so
hit that subscribe button and please
enjoy my conversation
with caroline berkel
[Music]
all right we're rolling berkel you're in
the house hey dude
it took a minute to make this happen i
think for a reason
yeah oh definitely for a reason yeah
well we met
was it like five years ago at this point
at that mind body green thing dude i saw
that picture the other day it popped up
in my
reminders memories thing yeah what year
was that
it might have been 2015. 2016 maybe
to send a jack right and it was
i remember it specifically i was like
dude we know i know the same person you
know
and it was like this moment where we
well it wasn't a selfie
it wasn't the kind of conference where
you expect to run into swimmers
yeah no yeah yeah so i didn't know who
you were and then we met we immediately
hit it off that was super fun to
establish that we both were friends with
jack roach who's this beautiful mentor
in the swimming community you know this
amazing human being who i know means so
much to you and
is a more recent friend of mine but
somebody who i care deeply about so that
was like our our
our meeting point our meet cute yes and
then uh we became friends ever since and
i think the last time
i saw you was that in
up in tahoe when we did that training
camp yes so it's been a couple years
that was 2017.
yeah there's a reason for that on my end
but here's the thing
the minute i met you i was like this
girl's lit like she would be great for
the podcast
but she's dealing with a few things i i
think i'll let her bake for a little
while
yeah you needed to let me sort a few
things out and i'm glad that i did like
you said these things
you know that timing is important and i
think the time
for this is perfect right now i think
had we done it
a couple years earlier it would be a
very different conversation
very different half of the things
wouldn't have i would have never
been aware of half of the things that i
would want to talk about
it wouldn't even have been in my
consciousness like it would have been
buried
seven layers deep yeah yeah yeah way
down maybe i could have teased it out
here yeah
you know fully embracing um this growth
trajectory that you've been on
and i think what's unique and
interesting about you as somebody who
has hosted several conversations with
olympians over the years and
and plenty of olympic swimmers most of
those conversations
are rooted in the olympic experience
itself
and we're going to talk about that with
you of course but what's most
interesting about
your story is the aftermath of that
and the kind of growth that you've
experienced
and the issues that you've wrestled with
you know post-career to
become this more actualized human being
yeah
it's been a ride yeah when i think back
i was actually listening to your podcast
with john moffett
sunday morning mm-hmm oh my god
i was just i was walking i was on my
like power walk for five six miles
because i'm trying to get some foot time
in right now like
trying to get back to running still
still on this like five year journey
back to running
and i was listening to that podcast with
him and it was just speaking to me
because he was like
i don't even remember that person right
i don't even remember the person that
competed in the games i remember this
other person that was
you know afterward and and um
the feelings that i had and the emotions
that went through
this process to transition and i
felt so seen right i feel seen i'm not
the only person
that feels like i just don't identify
with that one
you know olympic name in my life that
wasn't just
it for me right and i feel selfish i
feel selfish
saying that admittedly right now i feel
selfish thing
because you feel like it's such a gift
to have had that olympic experience and
with that there's some responsibility
that you shoulder to
communicate about it in a certain way
yeah because here i am 34 i run a
business
of olympic and professional athletes
that give back to the next generation
and i have shame associated with being
an olympian
so you know it's like this this pull of
both directions it's like you need to be
this and you need to be really proud of
it but you also like had this experience
with it and you're not
really wanting to claim and own some of
that experience
and so how can you settle in the middle
of that like what is that about
like where does the shame emanate from
where you want to start yeah let's start
at the beginning we can go all the way
back to the beginning
we can go back to the quarry pool in
kentucky
did you ever swim there i haven't but
it's on my bucket list
i love you know outdoor pools like that
i was in
austin a few weeks ago and i saw
portland springs
i just you know and when i was in
australia swimming at icebergs every day
like i love those people
i'm so jealous when you were there um
to answer to to sort of say the the
first thing first about the shame with
being an olympian
and the shame you know why is it that
it's so difficult to say that you have
that if you're also trying to
hold this image that you're proud of it
is that
i have this concept in my mind that i
cannot have
both i cannot have a feeling about
being an olympian that's negative and
also the feeling about being an olympian
that's positive
mm-hmm i i've been raised so you
defaulted the negative
yeah i'm sure you very well know that
i know you will i feel like not being an
olympian i can't own
that aspect of it but the feeling of
um
you know how could i be so
proud of it and also have so much um
trauma and shame associated with the
same thing mm-hmm
like how are both of those things
possible and i grew up growing up i
didn't think i could have two
feelings it was you had to have one
feeling
and it needs to be this and you need to
follow that like you're not allowed to
have multiple opinions and feelings and
and um or perhaps the shame is a result
of
not feeling the way that you feel like
you're supposed to feel about that
experience
right yeah because that's what hasn't
been ingrained is that that is just
that's it you've got to feel really good
about that but you know how lucky you
are
okay so should we start there because
that is something i've been unpacking a
lot
over the past couple years is um
growing up i grew up in this amazing
pool this great
city this wonderful family it was it was
wonderful
but the society that i grew up in in
louisville was very much
you should be very grateful for what you
have
don't question it this is the way it is
this is who you are and you know and i
and i grew up in this mindset of
well i have i can't have a darn bad
feeling to save my life because if i
have a bad feeling
or if i have a negative um feeling or
thought or emotion that comes up
then i'm a bad person my character is
bad
does that come from the parents the
parental units or
where does that idea germinate from
it comes from several avenues i grew up
in a very strict catholic school system
so church three times a week oh my
goodness
i mean so church three times a week you
know and it
i don't wanna like talk poorly about the
the system that it was but
i always felt like i was so different
than everybody there in the first place
so i grew up in this place where
everyone's telling me what to do and how
to do it
and i didn't like that i didn't like
that feeling of
why why do i have to think one way you
know
so it originated there this i have to
please
i can't have my own thoughts and
opinions and emotions i can't have more
than one feeling and it needs to be
positive
or else people will be upset with me
and so that whole thing that i've been
unpacking was sort of a pattern that i
continued to follow throughout my career
and my life
your brother doesn't seem to harbor that
though interestingly enough not as much
yeah so part of that perhaps is because
you were a girl
my father was tough yeah yeah so your
parents were both athletes your dad
owned all these
like fitness clubs right tennis tennis
and swim clubs
tennis and swimming so it was a very
active
ensemble yeah so he swam for uofl he
swam for lakeside he was like mary t's
teammate
him and mary t grew up together she
would kick his ass the whole thing you
know
so so mary t's got to be like a huge
looming presence in you know in the
swimming kind of lore of kentucky right
she's amazing for people that don't know
i mean she dominated
butterfly for years and set world
records that
at the time just seemed untouchable oh
my god madame butterfly
yeah i mean her stories the stories just
of her at
practice with her lungs collapsing and
her finishing ten five hundreds
butterfly
it's insane i'm like wait your your
lungs collapsed and you finished ten
five hundreds butterfly like
what are you talking about so you know
she was a legend there
and it was a gift to swim for lakeside
you know it was like you're lucky you're
in this
space where you're in this outdoor rock
quarry pool um
you should be so lucky and um
so yeah so my dad owned these fitness
clubs my mom was a tennis player so she
played professional top pro and
her whole mindset is she's from here
she's from california so she's just like
woo like you know you do you like i'mma
do me like
her whole deal is very
open mind free mind like she's just very
um spirited and my dad is very strict
and
you know dogmatic and follows the rules
and so the combo of them i think was
confusing for me as a child
because i felt this pull to like please
but then also like
you can do whatever you want and be
whoever you want please you can do
whatever you want and be whoever you
want and
but a little bit of each of those is
probably good absolutely
absolutely and they also you know grew
up in really
tough environments themselves so like
knowing where they came from and what
their background is
makes a whole lot of sense um so that's
sort of where all this originated
right is in this space of as a child
how can how could i have had
more than one feeling and not plea like
i had to please
but that came from everywhere well the
people pleasing
comes into play in a big way later down
the line we're going to work our way up
to that
but yeah at this early age
was it that was there an expectation
like you're going to be this
athlete or it was just it was kind of
the atmosphere that you were in right it
was just an active environment and you
were just
by dint of being your parents kid like
around a swimming pool all the time
yeah so they'd drop us off at 8 a.m pick
us up at 9 00 pm when it closed
we were at the pool all day long
i mean totally unsupervised just running
around like pool rats clark was
competing with every 18 year old
as a nine-year-old she's like let's
compete you know let's do this
uh i was not that way really
i had a very um
more of a calm demeanor with competition
like i didn't really i wasn't really
like a savage competitor
i didn't really have this like i'm gonna
do this and win and like i need to
train you know 20 hours a day and i had
this like i want to be here around my
friends
i enjoy the social aspect of it and i
really like this feeling of being a part
of a team in a community and
my suit's cute and you know all of these
different things that i could experience
as a young girl that felt like
um i was just free to be me in that
space like i could just be me
that's so interesting because that's
atypical of somebody who excels at the
highest level
right like you're have this kind of
freewheeling approach to the whole thing
was the talent immediately evident
from the beginning or did that how did
you grow into that aspect of
of being a true competitor
i had a lot of talent as a young girl i
had a lot of
natural just fluid talent
i was not a workhorse i was a racehorse
so you know i um didn't perform in
practice
so when people would see me as a little
girl they would have never guessed that
i was really
good because i was dog last and practice
all the time
um but then you'd get up on the blocks
for the race and win
yeah i had something at nate within me
that i could click on and off
very well i didn't have to show that or
prove that to people i didn't feel the
need to do that
swimming felt like this artistic
expression or something
internal that i could do that felt
like for one time in my day or in my
life or in my week i could feel free
and that i didn't have to do it for
anybody else
that's a very 2020 relationship to sport
but not a very
1995 relationship to sport but that's
why i felt so
outcast with ever like nobody understood
me
there wasn't a meet that went by as a
child um
in high school in college to where i
really felt
seen for how i performed and the way
that i trained and the way that i
saw my relationship with the sport i
wasn't obsessed with times
i wasn't obsessed with stats i didn't
know any of that
my brother was that right my brother was
like boom boom boom here's your time
here's your split but i'm like ah i
can't like
i'm trying to visualize what the
communication would have been like with
your coaches at the time then because
that must have been
frustrating or was it was it
was it a situation in which you know
they're they're trying to you know
jam this square peg into a round hole
and you're just doing your own thing
yeah mike deboer who do you know mike
mm-hmm
legend of two likes it likes like coach
legend of a coach um he got me
it took him a little bit but he got me
and so once i got into his group
so it's like you know bronze silver gold
pretty senior senior
like once i got into his senior group it
was like boom
i could feel seen i was which i know
it's a very
cliche term but now looking back
i felt so comfortable with him because
he understood the way that i performed
was in my body it was a somatic
experience of this feeling i was a
feeling athlete
and i i wasn't a thinking athlete i
didn't have
the stats and the splits and all of that
down i had no idea
no idea what i was going into at a meet
i had no idea what ranking i was i had
no idea i'd miss my races
all the time because i didn't pay
attention it's kind of like
hilarious and endearing though because
swimming is so
stats driven it's all about you know
what the pace clock is telling you and
your heart rate and you know you you
know kind of the splits that you need to
you know hit to
get your goal time and you know what the
olympic trials qualifying time is
and all of that stuff is like you know
imprinted onto the brain
but not for you no and i tried
i tried really hard i remember sitting
down and writing my goals and trying to
figure out my splits and i
remember these stories where i would sit
at the kitchen table
at our very first house you know
barberry lane
and my parents would sit there and help
me my mom of course had no she was not
into that either but my dad would sit
and help me with splits
and i just did not understand it there
was no comprehension
at all as a child like i it was right
over my head
and i tried like i tried really hard
and and i'm glad that i did because i
could see that side of it that's really
important to develop and understand but
i personally just i didn't it didn't
resonate with me so so i i suspect not
so good in math class
horrible yeah like failed the whole way
through
but like oddly enough like you know all
a's in language arts and
art and spelling and uh science and
social studies and all these other
classes but math
straight fail and i would go to tutors
and i you know i come on crying so much
just because i felt like
i was a failure because i wasn't the
same as everybody else
my school was a math and science school
it was heavy in that
and i was this artist this mind that was
free thinking and saw things abstractly
and
you know shapes and all and all these
things like i count things
by like this curtain right here i'll
count by the number of of
creases in it you know like i'm weird i
think of things in a very odd and
abstract way and that was not okay
like when i that was not okay that was
very confusing to people
and so once i started to uh realize that
i started to gear myself more towards
things like that in high school and
stuff i took art and ap
art and stayed in that lane but when it
came to swimming
i really had to work with mike on what
that looked like for me because i wasn't
the same as everybody else in the pool
interesting do you think that your
swimming career would have looked
different
if you just stayed in under his
tutelage the whole time oh yeah
because he understood you know yeah i
think there would have been a learning
curve
again and again and again as i went on
through the ranks of it
you know like i would have changed and i
would have grown and i would have gone
through xyz and it would have gone over
but oh i think about that all the time
just like what
i could have achieved or done
differently
and i suppose that's normal for people
to think about sure
but um yeah having to go to college then
and sort of relearn
or have a have a coach relearn me was a
whole exhaustion
exhausting process we're getting up to
that but but first was there
i'm wondering whether there was like an
inflection point early in your career
when you were still in high school where
you were like
oh man like i'm really good at this like
was there a race or an event or
something that occurred that that you
know it dawned upon you like i've got a
real
bright future yes so
um i was a breast joker first
so that's weird yeah i wouldn't have
thought that i was my first
junior national cut and my first senior
national cut
so how old were you when you first made
junior nationals 13.
yeah okay i didn't go why not
because i wasn't ready according to who
me so i had this uh who doesn't go
and that's a big deal when you're a
young kid and you make that that
qualifying time
i i uh
i i remember so it was at the university
of kentucky i made it in the 100
brushstroke
and i got out and i remember my brother
was like pumping his chest just like
happier than i was
i was like sick i made this cut like i
don't even care you know it was this
weird thing and he's like dude you know
what that means like
you know what that means you get to go
to this meet in orlando and all this
stuff and i'm like
no i'm not going i started crying on
deck and mike looked at me and
he is like i could cry right now and you
know me i'm very like vulnerable
and emotional so thanks for for bearing
with me but he
um he he looked at me and he goes
you don't you don't want to go and i
said no i'm not ready for that
yet i'm not there yet and he was like
okay
that's a impressive level of
self-awareness for a young person though
i was extremely self-aware i i don't but
how much of that was just
fear of the unknown versus
self-understanding
certainly fear 100 fear
but my fear was stemming from going
there and not
making people happy if i performed
poorly so my fear was never that i
wouldn't do well
because my fear didn't how do i say this
um like without sounding weird uh i
i had a really strong trust in my
ability
i knew i wasn't gonna be a bad swimmer
my fear was that i wouldn't please
people
my fear was that i'd go and i'd fail and
people would be upset with me
and if they're upset with me that means
i'm a bad person and then if i'm a bad
person that means
you know whatever else it means but it
doesn't sound like your parents
cared that much so it wasn't coming from
them was it
that's the crazy thing is they were
extremely hands-off with my swimming
my mom didn't even know what like i'd
i'd swim and she would say
like oh my god like that was you know it
was a great swim
mom i just added 10 seconds you know she
had no she was just you but you were the
cutest one out there i'm like thanks mom
you know
my dad was more in tuned um but they
they never
made me feel badly for any of my
performances
so i've started to realize that i was
running from something throughout this
time
and then i kept running which we'll get
to but i was running from something and
i think i just have this
um and i had this very strong
fear of upsetting people and i still
think you know i think if you ask
anybody that where does that come from
sure you can pinpoint a person or a
place or a thing or whatever
but truthfully you create a story about
where that comes from
you know you create what that looks like
and then you have this whole scenario in
your head about why you're not pleasing
people
and i was so imaginative that my stories
were seven
ceilings high you know yeah to me it
almost sounds like
fear of your own strength and power
yeah that if you were to go to a meet
like that and actually
excel at the level that innately you
knew you were capable of that that would
actually be the thing that would upset
people
not failing but actually being
as awesome as you knew that you could be
like that might ruffle feathers does
that
fit yeah you struck a chord just there
um
for sure because upsetting people to me
was not being liked right so if i'm not
liked
which is the same thing as what you're
saying if i beat other girls
if i do you know what does that mean
right
they don't like me and if i'm not liked
by these girls or by these people
then i'm a bad person right it all stems
back to this like innate
worthiness within myself that like i'm
just not a good person
if that happens which is so interesting
how that manifested at such a young age
but i
this happened all the time i would let
people beat me i would literally let
people beat me and meet sometimes
because i was afraid to win
yeah i'd be looking around and they
would be passing me and i would be like
relieved
it was crazy right right right and
really and then i'd get to the wall and
just be so upset
because i knew that i could have won and
i still have my best races in my life
knew i could have
gone seven seconds faster than that it
was more important to you
to fit in than it was to
excel at the level you were capable of
yeah
yeah and it's it's a very um
it's an intense emotion to revisit
because you know then you think well
what could i have done and how can i
how do you train somebody to not give a
[ __ ] about what people think and like
how do you catch this and like you know
you could go down the rabbit hole of all
the ways i could have done it
differently
but the truth of the matter is as a
young woman
i didn't feel worthy enough
and bottom line the issue is i didn't
feel worthy enough
and so that you know as a woman and as a
young girl i
would imagine so many people feel the
same way and i know for a fact
yeah that's everyone's human that's the
thing i mean you know some people
maybe the majority of people listening
to this might struggle to
connect with or relate to you know the
high highs of your career and going to
the olympics and all of that but that
experience that you just related i think
is
highly relatable especially particularly
to young
female athletes yeah or young females in
general
because i i don't think it's a thing
that many
guys go through yeah but you can see it
with young girls all over the place all
over the place and
there's nothing wrong with it i think
it's just we're catching it faster
you know like we're able to catch it
faster people are becoming more aware
coaches can become more aware
parents friends peers can become more
aware when someone's like i'm not good
enough
i don't want this person be mad at me
you know that's being caught faster i
think
so that these young women can actually
move up a little
a little better and feel a little
stronger and a little more empowered and
you know i say all this and it's i i'm
so human like i don't have a problem
with saying
i like knew that i was amazing and also
freaked out that people wouldn't like me
mm-hmm like but yeah the idea so real
that idea of i'm not good enough but but
also the idea of it's not okay to be too
good
right yeah yeah yeah too much yeah yeah
you still
you still stumble forward and you know
continue to
excel as you mature as an athlete yeah
so that must have been a little war that
you were waging in your in your
in your consciousness yeah it it's a
trip to think back to
when you're young and to start unpacking
you know i don't know if you've ever
done stuff like this where you just go
back and
it's not just the past 10 years but it's
the 10 before that and then you start to
realize
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure you have just
gonna throw that out there
but um it's it's so
fascinating to see the patterns
and the different things that you uh
you thought were just this problem and
you need to push down
and when you can finally just say it and
be like
i was afraid of being too much and i was
not i didn't think i was enough
and just say it right and like get it
off your body and let it out of your
system it's like
oh okay i feel better now and now where
do i start
right and it's confusing because those
two ideas seem
at odds with each other how can you
possibly harbor both of those thoughts
at the same time
it goes back to the two thoughts part
right like you can't i can't have both
of those so it just must be one
and i just need to stick with it and
deal with it and shove it down
and move on and keep competing and make
everybody happy and then it's like
whatever you know and that was my
mindset is it's just like
well just keep going yeah you know yeah
the the the alcoholic disposition
is you feel like you're superior
to everybody and you know more than
anybody else and you're more capable
than anyone else and at the same time
you're a complete piece of [ __ ]
and yeah don't deserve anything yeah and
those two
identities coexisting at the same time
neither of which are true right and we
create these stories that
become such a reality and especially if
you're an imaginative soul and you have
all these
you know little fairy tales in your mind
artistic sensibility caroline
like nothing is in like a linear
sequence in your brain you've got like
12 different
allison wonderlands going on so it's
like oh that must be true oh that must
be true
well that's true you know and you're
picking from all these parts of yourself
and i think that's where i could that
was a blessing but it could also be a
curse
for me as a swimmer and as a human in
general
but it was it it was a lot to unpack
when i finally did i was
there's a lot of shame that comes with
that because
you feel i think
what i started to really pick apart
i guess i don't know if that's the right
word but dissect
was how is it possible
to hold space for something like that
like how is it possible to hold space
for
um parts of you that you have a lot of
shame in
parts of you that you have a lot of um
grief like
you grieve parts of yourself with people
pleasing which is a weird thing as well
um and also not sound like a victim all
the time or like you're complaining
you know so doing that works hard
because you don't know how to
say it and and feel like you can own it
and claim it because you don't want to
complain
you don't want to sound like you're
coming you don't want to be a burden to
other people too
with that so i just didn't and i just
didn't for
however long and how'd that work out
horribly
yeah all right
so uh by the time you're a senior
in high school though you're crushing it
i assume you're getting recruited at all
these colleges
you're probably rocking out the nag
you know records and all that kind of
stuff at that point
yeah um so my college
recruiting experience was really
interesting
i went to arizona texas northwestern
florida
cal and stanford stanford
my mom was like let's go to california
you know
my dad's like no so
i ended up having to choose between
arizona and florida because i wanted to
train with the guys
mm-hmm i loved training with you this is
the only two programs where they trained
together
yeah end up changing so what was that
about
why was that important this is this is
like kind of strange so um
i somehow knew that first of all i
trained with guys at lakeside tons of
guys there was like
five people on the senior team that were
girls the rest were dudes
my brothers were i grew up around guys
like a lot of guy cousins i just
i liked that energy for training um i
didn't even know what it was like to
really train with all girls so i was
sort of just
biased right off the start but i also
knew that the men backstrokers
in the 200 were equivalent to what i
wanted to be in the 200 free
i didn't know times but i remember my
brother saying to me
if you want to go really fast and you're
200 free you need to train with dudes in
the 200 back
because it's the same time and i was
like whatever that means but so
so you know i checked the box of looking
at university of florida palm trees like
mike deboer's best friend
martin wilby was one of the coaches um
you know men and women's team warm
weather and a lot of male backstrokers
so i can train with them isn't that
weird and i ended up doing it my whole
career too
right well you're you're somebody who
has a lot of guy friends like
it feels like most of your friends are
dudes yeah you know so
not i think the word masculine has a
pejorative when
used in association with somebody who's
a woman but there's like a
there is a masculine aspect to how you
carry yourself socially
yeah yeah i like to hang yeah and you're
super tight with your brother
yeah yeah and i i really needed that
experience and i wanted that experience
and
and then he ended up going there right
and that was like
you transferred though right yeah yeah
there's a lot that went on with that
just a lot of yeah there's a lot that
went on with that but
you know greg troy recruited me to
university of florida
um and he was my main coach throughout
the years there
and that you know that's the whole up
and down
relationship between him and i um
but yeah so i went to university of
florida i end up signing with them
full scholarship um went in my freshman
year
oh man i had the best freshman year um
out of all the years really actually um
200 free 500 free at secs won the med
secs with second both at ncaas
and then my sophomore year came around
and i had so many expectations
and i just swam like crap i mean it was
a rough year for me
i am so what what was the change like
what do you attribute that dip to
expectations yeah so
so suddenly you're this artistic
personality who kind of
just goes with the flow and suddenly
you're in a position where you're
actually paying attention to all that
stuff that everybody had been telling
you all along that you needed to pay
attention to
yeah and it had the opposite effect yeah
so all of a sudden i had to pay
attention to times like you said you
know
um and coming in as a freshman there's
no expectation it's just
you know go and greg troy you know
put a lot of pressure on me my sophomore
year he also had me training in the
distance group
so anthony nesty was my coach and nesty
is amazing he's
the greatest human but every day i'd
walk on the pool deck
on the outdoor pool deck where the
distance group trained and
he would say why are you out here
i don't know why you're out here and i'm
like i don't either i don't you know i
cannot do four one thousands for time
right like that's not the way i train
so i started um i started doing this
distance training and
stepping out of the weight room and then
into the pool more and training straight
distance and my body didn't respond
i have pretty sensitive adrenals and so
it was like boom i was you know
severely underweight i wasn't training
well i wasn't competing well
um i got sick a few times i was also in
an
unhealthy relationship for the first
year of my life and so it was just like
coming from every angle was like the
great storm of
oh dear god like now i have to like
prove myself
and people don't like me again and i'm
not well and i don't know what to do
um was there pressure to lose weight
yeah yeah every day i went
on the pool deck i was told either you
know tighten it up or go on an extra run
this week or
um you know there were specific groups
for extra runs and stuff
and i was not
anywhere near needing to do an extra run
and that was uh that was
a really really hard time for me i
i didn't know either how to i didn't
have a voice i didn't speak up i didn't
say a damn word
you know because i believed in what was
going on i believed in it
and i just remember being so confused
like i don't understand
why i'm being told these things like why
am i not enough
so we're back to that again yeah well
you have a certain level of success
in your you know you're this big fish in
a small pond in kentucky
but then you know for people that are
unfamiliar
like the university of florida was a
mecca of swimming you were in that
bubble pool right that like
yeah that epic architectural pool that
is that still there i love that pool yep
a little five lane outdoor pool right uh
greg troy legendary coach
anthony nesty olympic gold medalist in
the hunter fly
from suriname right right right right
nom i remember they
when he won the gold medal they like
they put him on the currency
like he was such a national hero oh yeah
he would go back for parades and they'd
parade him around in a chair you know
the whole deal and
he married this beautiful tall redhead
woman and they had the most
amazing little girl like i mean he was
just fantastic
and um you know honestly unfortunately
he was the distance coach so i didn't
have a lot of interaction with him after
sophomore year what was the decision
that you needed to go into the distance
program because i mean that ends up
being your thing
but that wasn't what you arrived
thinking you were going to be doing
he wanted me to swim the mile
he wanted me to because i don't know i
don't know i really don't know
well he was kind of right yeah i mean i
was good at the 500
and that was like the 800 meters yeah
yeah
but i i wasn't mentally a miler that
wasn't
my thing i was a very much 500
that went toward the 200 and not the
other way
um but i mean
the amount we trained you know you know
john's interview with you oh my god i
mean we were
training four times a day four times a
day
yeah we had morning practice we had
weights and dry land
and we had afternoon practice so morning
go to class go to weights
go back to dry land go to afternoon
practice eat two
two two pull sessions and two gym
sessions every day
yeah yeah and i and you're looking like
tapped
maybe 15 000 yards a day or something
yeah some days way more but i was
just tapped you know and so um i
i think there was a belief that i needed
more training
and i remember one day i walked into the
pool deck
sophomore year and it was like four
two thousand no nine one nine sixteen
fifties
uh-huh and yeah i mean i'm not kidding
rich like
i start crying like immediately start
like and
i was i didn't know what to do 16.50 is
a mile and
nine nine one mile repeats in the pool
i mean let's put it this way it takes
from two until like seven
so i just started crying on like the
18 minutes or something like that yeah
and so nessie comes up to me and he puts
his hands on my shoulders and he was
like
you're gonna be okay i don't know if i
am actually you know i'm gonna give this
a try but um
they pulled me out at four so that day i
only did four but i'll never forget
uh i got out at four and they still had
five more they didn't finish
like seven by the way 7pm um
and i called mike deboer and i'm sitting
on the side of the pool
the outdoor pool like over in a corner
on my little flip
cell phone you know it's like 2005 and a
half or whatever
and uh i just said something's not right
i'm not i'm not doing what i need to be
doing here like something isn't right
and and he was just he talked me through
it like we know
what are you training what's going on
whatever i guess what happened was he
ended up talking to one of the coaches
wilby will be talked to troy and it was
like we need to switch around her
training again
like she can't be training this way it's
not working for her
so they end up putting me back in the
weight room two extra days a week and
putting me in the middle distance group
and breaststroke group
like brushstroke i am and i started
swimming way better
like lights out um so you know the
balance of that but also i think
as i sort of have reflected on that
feeling seen from mike
and then having a conversation
with my coach and connecting on that
level and having a real conversation
about what's happening with my body
why my cycles are gone you know why i'm
sick all the time
why my blood work sucks like getting
real with the actual biological effects
of
what's gone on inside my body with that
over training
was eye-opening for them and also you
know for me
because i didn't i've never been over
trained before really like i didn't
understand what that felt like
um so that
really was a um the first time in my
life i saw the combination of the mind
body
working together to um
kind of pivot me back on course right
right i didn't have that connection
before
i always you know so to kind of refer
back to what i was saying earlier
i always sort of felt weird because i
had that innately
i knew that i was a somatic experiencer
and i felt things in my body but i
didn't understand that
the brain and the body were working
together to feel things and that where
you feel one you feel the other
it's very similar to john moffatt's
trajectory
because he was you know a guy who
couldn't handle that kind of volume
but had the self-awareness and and
and the boundaries the healthy
boundaries to say like i'm not going to
that morning workout like it's not
in service to the goals that i've set or
of the team and i think people don't
understand how difficult it is to
to create that boundary because you're
part of this program that's legendary
and this is what we do here
so get in the pool and don't ask
questions i used to have
my academic advisor tim i pull me out of
workouts
because he knew how drained and tired i
was like my grades were suffering
and he would just have me sit in
the osl the office of student life over
in the corner and tell coach that i had
a tutor quote-unquote because i was so
drained yeah
i would just sleep and it takes a long
time to emerge out of that
super long i felt very guilty held a lot
of guilt there because it felt like
everyone else is training but i was also
going through trauma like i was also
going through
a very unhealthy situation with a
relationship and so
not only that my whole system's in
sympathetic 24 7
showing up to the pool you know with
zero hours of sleep
because i'm up all night the night
before going through whatever i'm going
through and i
get to the you know that i wasn't even
accounting for that like i didn't
realize how much
that was playing a part in my
performance
and it was like eye-opening to me to
finally realize that that was
working against me like all of these
factors were working against me and if i
didn't align myself
in the right path mind and body i wasn't
going to go anywhere
but you emerge out of that yeah um
senior year ncaas was like
the big emergence out of it i slowly
emerged but
um that was my probably my favorite
person was that
2008 yeah so 2008
you break the nc2a record in the 500
free
yeah and that was the longest standing
record at the time right was it janet
evans yeah i mean that's pretty
epic that was my favorite performance it
was like
433 or something like that yeah and i
um i ripped two suits before that and
i remember just being totally in flow
like i don't remember that race at all
i touched the wall and i had oodles of
energy i could have gone for another
500.
and i remember just being like holy [ __ ]
like trials are in three months i'm
gonna do this like i remember that
thought going through my mind like the
moment that i touched the wall
i'm going to the olympics yeah and also
with that comes a lot of you know
pressure but uh that moment was really
powerful for me because
it was the first time that i felt like i
really hit that stride of
feeling and flow and seeing the struggle
throughout my college career
come to a place where i could put aside
these distractions that i
had you know going on at the exact same
time and use
the tools that i had to make something
happen
you know it felt like what were the what
were those tools specifically at that
time
i went from not doing any sort of
mindset work
at all or really understanding what that
was to focusing in on
that kind of stuff breath work i don't
know if you'd call it meditation
but i journal i'd um visualization felt
visualization imagery i wrote all my
goals and images
and pictures and none of my goals were
in times my locker had like the pictures
or like an icon of something like a
banana and that banana reminded me of
like whatever i wanted to do was i
you know i was weird so um
so that was a big factor in that
those tools but also
i think i felt i felt very aligned with
with coach troy at that time
because um right before that year
we had a huge you know conversation
about
the way i perform what i need to go
and do in practice um and a lot of that
stemmed around like
tempo work visualization work like our
conversations were about that like he
saw me you know for the first time in
that relationship as a coach to swimmer
and i was able to really turn that
around and
so i think it was the connection with
him
like the connection that i felt
finally after however many years of
feeling true
connection with this person yeah trust
communication
clarity um
so instead of this uh resistance
that we had like he doesn't get me i
don't get her
he doesn't get me i don't get her it was
like
one conversation one one two hour
conversation could really change
the trajectory of what i was going to do
based on
sharing what works for me and how i can
be a better student of whatever it is
that i need to get done
through the methods that my brain
understands the learning styles of my
brain so forming some kind of
partnership
yeah type of relationship yeah
so trials comes up three months later
three months later
it's an interesting one because you end
up
making the olympic team by getting
fourth in the 200 freestyle
but you got a bunch of force right and a
fifth like yeah
and 100 free 400 free i barely and then
i would have
meddled at the actual olympics with the
times i went so
i know it was a pretty it's like yeah
it's like it's got to be like
mixed emotions because you didn't
actually qualify in an individual event
yeah you were just one place shy of of
getting that
you still met all at the olympics in the
relay you swam the preliminaries and
then and
also in the finals so they bumped you up
yeah mm-hmm did you just rock out a
split they didn't expect or
yeah um so this is where
things kind of get interesting my
olympic trials
was uh
a pretty emotional ride for me
um i was going through like the thick of
some traumatic experiences literally at
the trials like
in the process of that meaning like
relationship stuff yeah okay
yeah so uh
i think you know as i've as i've worked
through that too
um that is where some of that resentment
and shame comes from because i think to
myself
could i have been better had i not
had that kind of experience distracted
by
a boyfriend situation that wasn't
working out right yeah
um so
let's see i made it in the well the 400
free
i missed it by a spot 200 free i made it
and then the 100 free and the 800 free i
was like
fifth s fifth fourth something like that
um and you know
the the trials are so intense it's the
most intense me
way more intense in the olympics but you
know gearing up toward the olympics this
was the year that prelims were at night
and finals were in the morning in
beijing so um
you know really having to change how i
trained like
i was a night swimmer now i had to be a
boat swimmer right
now i had to be a morning a preliminar
final the whole thing
uh but you know that was it was a really
important time
um olympic trials were a really
important time to get to
the games i think i wish i would have
made it an individual event
for sure i still feel that
but i also am so proud of myself
for how i handled everything else that
was going on and the way that i was able
to show up
during the darkest part of my life like
the
i was in the darkest one of the darkest
parts of my life before i even made the
team
and so you know yes the transition was
really dark but
that part right before was really hard
to pull myself out of
were you keeping all that private though
or were you letting people
help you i had one person helping me my
counselor
at school i didn't talk to anybody about
it my parents had no idea
my teammates my roommates knew because
they lived with me
um but i didn't have any you know
conversations with people about it and
great
mm-hmm uh you know
they did but nothing's complicated yeah
they can't do anything about it
so when you reflect back on your olympic
experience i mean how do you
how do you think about it now versus
then
i feel like it was the beginning of my
life
in a weird way like it was like the
first
of so much to come
and it was a springboard for sure for a
lot of different reasons
um but it was the beginning of my life
in that i was able to
to look at i'm able to look at it and
know that i have sort of been reborn
again from that experience like i was a
certain way leading up to it
and this experience happens and it's
easy for people to say sure you go to
the olympics of course you're reborn you
know it's this big achievement
but personally internally the way my
nervous system was wired the way my
whole body and my being are in this
world
i was able to sort of start there and
say what's been working
and what hasn't and and
you know how can i go from here did i
know that at the time
no did i know that 10 years after no do
i look at it now and say
oh wow that was a beautiful
thing and i'm so glad that i can look at
that experience and say
holy [ __ ] i stood on the podium in front
of the world and also
can see every age of caroline berkel
two four six eight ten tall every age of
myself there
showing up to that podium every single
age until that moment
and that's really special because to me
it doesn't symbolize this like 200 free
like yay that's great
but it's to get there it took all
versions of me
and then to go from there it's going to
take a whole different
carolinas yeah and i think that feeling
and that realization
is powerful to feel that you can have
stages of your life like that
what are people not fully understand
about
the olympic experience i mean i suspect
it's got to be
disorienting to go from
you know churning out sets
in gainesville to suddenly being you
know foisted onto the nation the
international stage and being on
television
in a bathing suit for all the world to
you know
cast their judgments on and their
opinions
it's definitely um
it really challenges your focus it
challenges your ability to stay in your
lane
and to be able to to block things out
really well
uh especially with media and with with
other things going on luckily then we
didn't have a lot of media
there wasn't we didn't have phones at
the olympics right we didn't have i mean
facebook was online but it wasn't there
was no iphone or anything like that
no social media no iphones we didn't
have any technology in the village
the village is a very you know dense
experience there's just a lot of people
obviously vying for the same thing so
the energy is just palpable you can feel
it from everybody
but there's also this camaraderie it's
beautiful you know you see every country
and every
walk of life and uh it's a really
special experience and you see a lot
that you've never seen before too as a
girl from kentucky in florida and
i mean i'm seeing the world right you're
seeing the world right in front of you
and you have to really
check yourself with what you've you know
been
thinking your whole life and and put
your judgment aside and be able to to
hone in on really
what you're doing accept everybody and
kind of move forward because that's the
point of the olympics
right is to accept everybody the rings
symbolize that unity of the world
together um so it is a special
experience where you're trying to
compete against each other but you're
really trying to bring everybody
together
as a the world into this special place
to achieve this goal do you feel like
in the wake of that you you departed
beijing thinking
i'm just starting like i got a bunch of
force and i was on this relay and i got
a medal but you know my individual time
would have meddled in this event like
i'm getting back to work no no
um i knew i was bummed
that i couldn't have meddled on my own
but i was so burnt out at that point
i was beyond ready
to walk away and to run away
um you know i was listening to apollo's
podcast with you and he just you know
some of the things he said struck a
chord
too just with you know the weight of
gold and how that all works right
and we can go down that path but it's a
it's a whole
um it's a whole experience
of what now
right and that's the easiest way to say
it
but there really is no better way to say
it yeah it it's daunting
and also you can't be bothered
to go back into the fire some like we're
so good
as athletes at focusing and at pivoting
our focus so we pivot
to running and you don't look back that
way because you're really damn good at
what you do
so you're going to focus this way
instead of focusing
but you don't know what to focus that
spotlight on that's the problem
and on paper like from a academic
perspective you know who wouldn't want
to hire
an olympian these people know how to
work hard they know how to set a goal
they know how to achieve it they know
how to show up
under pressure and overcome obstacles
like they just seem like the ultimate
candidate for the marketplace but
it doesn't work that way and i think the
the more often than not it is the weight
of gold where
they become they have this existential
crisis like what am i supposed to do now
i've never thought about
this because getting to where they got
to achieve what they achieved
required every ounce of focus and
discipline
and intention there just wasn't any time
to
ponder what comes after and there aren't
structures in place to help athletes
with that transition
no no so that's why i think that movie
was so you know
so powerful and instructive it was
incredible
i watched it a few times and was just
sobbing my eyes out
because again it goes back to that same
conversation of how can you be feeling
two things at once like
right so proud like sick you know lolo
jones like sick i just won this medal
and also i'm making smoothies you know
so
it's like how can you be so angry and
harbor this anger and frustration
at what you've done and also be so proud
and
so excited that you've done this thing
and can't wait to like tell your friends
and like do you know even though they
know
can't wait to do all these other things
and
but you can't tell your friends that you
feel that way no
so much shame with that because they
would think you're an entitled spoiled
brat or you know that was my story
no one wants to hear that sob story you
know and michael phelps says it really
well too he says the same thing like i
i couldn't possibly tell people i was
depressed i had 700 gold medals
like there's no way i could tell
somebody that i'm depressed like there's
no way that i could share
you know that i've had suicidal thoughts
there's no way that i could share that
you know i was in a traumatic situation
a relationship there's no way that i
could share that
um you know god
i that that that i
hated myself at a certain part of you
know day four the olympics you know
there's no way you can share these
specific
feelings because
what then what would what would people
think of you right
right you're you're you're a bulletproof
olympian
yeah you've got to be superman you know
you've got to be
this special um force
that you know people would kill to be in
your shoes and and
um so yeah you could never say
something that would um
jeopardize your olympic status
yeah because then
if people find out and not only people
but media let's say media finds out
and they're oh she's complaining about
that
yeah she's got a bad attitude so there's
a bad olympian
right yeah and the the um
psychology of it is changing because i
think there's a lot of awareness now
around the fact that you can be
depressed or having a difficult time or
going through something traumatic and
also perform
that both of those are okay again back
to the two things
yeah well i mean i think you know
michael is to be credited yeah you know
considerably for the work that he's done
to expand that awareness
huge and i mean when you you've
we're on the olympic team with him like
is there when you're you've spent a lot
of time with them i presume like you
know him well
uh you know was there any indi like
i'm sure your your your relationship
with him is when you're at swim meets
right so you don't see that aspect of it
yeah no and we saw it with michael
though just because he's
he's vulnerable like he could show he
wears his emotions
you know on his sleeve and so you could
see him struggling
but you don't know to what extent you
don't know if that's just you know
at that point in time we're all so laser
focused you don't know if that's just
like
with training or with you know not going
times you want to go
or whatever it is you just assume that
that person is struggling for another
reason
not with worth even though
i was struggling with work so it's like
you can feel it but we just know it was
like hush
but no one would ever utter those words
yeah we all feel this way but no one's
saying anything
you know so he was like the cat's out of
the bag like he broke the mold there of
we've all been feeling this and somebody
just needs to say it yeah
because we're all feeling it and walking
around with this like weird thing where
everyone's awkward and
oh yeah i'm great how are you i'm great
you know years later and it's like
that's not the case like let's just say
it how it is and also you can be
struggling and be proud of your
experience at the same time
no one's telling you you can't have both
yeah you know and i think that a lot of
us felt like we couldn't have both
so you kind of cut and run right like
you just you just walked away from the
pool for
a little while i mean you found your way
back to it but you took
this break so i cut and run
i didn't look one direction from a pool
for
years first time i stepped inside of
years
years probably two and a half oh wow
i retired in 2010 first time i stepped
back foot
stepped foot back into a pool was
clark's olympic trials
and that was like really hard for me
um i cried so much at that meet by
myself in the hotel room in omaha and
i was so proud of my brother like i have
never seen a better race than his
race to make the olympic team in that
200 breaststroke
he's hands down the best underwater
pullout kid in the world
i mean he's insane he's so strong and i
was so proud of him and so emotional
there at that meet um but i of course
didn't show anybody i cried in my hotel
room
because of course that couldn't be seen
brother sister
duos that have both become olympians
there must be
uh crippens i believe
um or no maybe i'm thinking of something
else i don't know i don't think so
maybe in other sports right in swimming
there's sister
sisters like haley and uh alyssa
anderson
um no but that was
that was the first time so you can
imagine i run away and the first time i
come back
is around the exact same world the world
i ran away from
and i had a purpose my purpose was to
support my brother
so i was able to again block out my
stuff
handle it on my own and be there for him
and i treated that whole olympic trials
like i was competing
my ass was up at 4 am going on a run
getting ready
eating breakfast like the whole like i
felt like i was in the experience but i
i was not experienced like i wasn't in
that experience
um but so he makes the team and then we
go to london
and that again it's like my second meet
back
and that was really difficult for me so
throughout this whole process
um difficult but proud so i mean i can't
tell you like i was way more proud of my
brother than i ever was of myself
it's crazy how that works uh and
i get to um oh well throughout that
process i was like
struggling with some body dysmorphia
some
disordered eating wasn't healthy let's
put it that way
um at all like just
full stop wasn't healthy wasn't eating
wasn't
taking care of myself didn't feel worthy
of love
period i didn't have that my system had
been in overdrive
i had been in sympathetic literally four
years
and i had not come down my body was
churning
every last morsel of energy just to get
through that meat
and i got back from that meat and i just
like
crashed like my sis my body just started
to break down like it was
this whole thing um with that but
that was the that was sort of the first
realization that i had i wasn't healthy
right so between 2008
the olympics you walking away from the
sport and 2012 when you
you don't really return to swimming but
you return to the
culture right to support your brother a
lot there's a lot that happened
right so i wanna spend a little bit of
time here i mean you you end up
you know you're trying to find your way
you get a fashion degree
you gotta fit them right and you're
working with some apparel brands and
you're employed
you're trying to figure it out um but i
feel like there's a
a crucial event that takes place that i
think
um you know puts you deeper into that
psychological hole and that happens
around 2010. so can we talk about that a
little bit
yeah so um
i had transferred from the fitum oc
campus to the la campus
so i was living with hayley pearsall um
and aaron came to visit for like three
months
classic aaron move uh is he like living
in costa rica now or something i guess
yeah but he came to live with us he just
lived with us i was on the corner of los
ciena and i got an olympic like
what am i doing right right in l.a l.a
and i was you know i was working for lou
lemon
um i just like i didn't know what to do
you know so um
i was sitting in my apartment one night
and
uh i get like
multiple calls and on my phone one after
the next i'm like who is this unknown
number i don't understand what's going
on
and uh then i got a bunch of text
messages and voicemails
um that were left and uh
i had just retired from swimming so
literally a month retired
fresh i had been training you know for
context at fullerton aquatic club
with sean hutchison and
and what was the intention of the
training at that time because this is
two
this is two years after the olympics
like were you thinking you're
was it because you just couldn't let go
of it and didn't know what else to do or
did you have designs on
some some lofty goals
i i was just running i was chasing
different things to check off the list
that i could just
do like i needed something to feel
worthy i needed to
have something to show so i just kept
doing things
i was collecting accolades and degrees
and all these things and i was like oh
yeah i'll just do all these things
distract myself you're living on olympic
in la cienega and you're driving to
fullerton to swim i mean that's a
hike yeah i mean i did that just until i
retired and then i was like i can't do
this anymore because you had to transfer
campus for it for fitment i got it
but um i felt like i just had to prove
myself in the sport you know like i felt
like i needed to finish it off and prove
myself and
um and when i retired i retired at
irvine nationals
um i knew i
knew my last race i knew it going into
it
i knew the moment i did the 200 free i
was in lane one i swam horrible i got
out i started
went to the diving well put my goggles
on try to not let anybody see me cry and
amanda beard of course
comes over and puts her arm on my
shoulder and she was you know she was an
angel for me my whole career
by the way she was an angel at the
training camp with some coach situations
she was an
angel you know afterward she just said
like
you're gonna be okay you may not know
what what you're gonna do but you're
gonna be okay
and i was like okay and you know this is
coming from somebody that's like started
the sport seven different times and
you know had a crazy cool career and
child and you know all these things and
so
i just let it be and i just walked away
from the sport
but i walked away from the sport because
i was tired of the politics and the
feelings that i got about
my worth as a human being and my body
and my butt like i was just tired i i
just needed to get away like it was so
exhausting to always feel like i was
like
an object of or a project or you know
something
that i couldn't i couldn't uh
figure out how to find my love for it
again so like why not just run away
i don't want to keep trying and forcing
this if i'm just going to feel angry at
it
and that was my reason for stopping i
was tired i was tired of
what was going on i was tired of feeling
like i was just
like i said this object or this project
or not enough
or needed to be somebody for these
coaches or these people i just like
wanted to be
and it was such a powerful feeling
within me that i was just so tired of
that
and so i just ran away and that's when i
had a lot of different things happening
right but i
i fully ended my career
on a very intense like
bodily feeling that i had to go right
like i
had to go like it was just too much
for me um and also
like that i knew that i did
what i i i got out what i put in that i
that you know that i
got what i came for i did what i wanted
to do
yeah um but oh
i just feel it in my body when i talk
about that moment
that moment was so powerful it was i was
sitting on the side of the pool and i
was ending this thing
it's like you're breaking up with this
thing you've been with for 25 years or
whatever and it was just this
this is what this is how it is this is
this is how it's going to end just kind
of
petering out in a local meet yeah and
the subpar performance yeah yeah subpar
performance really not good
and proud of myself for continuing but
you know i just wanted to prove myself
and when i realized that i just didn't
need to be in it anymore
i needed to find something else and i
knew that i could and i knew that i
could
could be rebirthed in my life and i had
that feeling that that would happen
i just didn't know how yeah i had no
idea how i had no idea what i was going
to do
well you moved to la cienega in olympic
and start working for our lululemon
apparently and then i walked the santa
monica stairs every day that's good
that's my workout
uh yeah so i moved there i lived with
haley
and then aaron came to came to live with
us and i was just very depressed during
that time
um i
don't really recall any
moments that felt like pure joy for me
you know i um i was really struggling
during that time it was really hard for
me it's when i started to hide
i started to inch my way into the little
hole
step by step and it was right around
this time that you start
you got this evening occurred where you
get these weird text messages
yeah um
and that felt like the last straw for me
like that was like the last straw for me
so i i get
so expensive explain what happened yeah
yeah
um so
my coach sean from fast uh
was out with coach bowman one night and
i guess
you know whatever they were doing they
decided to
send me some vulgar text messages and
voicemails
and it involved myself and
um some of my brother and just
things that were very traumatizing for
me as a 20
i don't know three-year-old girl that
had just retired from the sport and also
run away from
that exact thing that exact
experience of
you know abuse in a lot of ways and so
i was just done like that
that moment was traumatizing for me and
it felt like um my initial reaction
was that i needed to turn them in so i
turned
the messages in right so let's just
contextualize it a little bit
yeah sean hutchinson was the swim coach
at fast
and you know was a well regarded coach
who had
birthed many a career um bob bowman
is michael you know famous for being
michael phelps's coach so you get these
weird
text messages from unknown numbers and
it turns out it's
bob and sean and they're off color
they're off-putting they're distasteful
we don't need to get into exactly what
they said but there's articles out there
if you want to read about it
it's been reported in the press but it
was
highly highly inappropriate and
it also was a glimpse into you know
some things that sean had been doing
that he shouldn't been doing with
a with with a a friend of yours a
swimmer ariana coucours
uh that that then kind of precipitated
after you report this a whole kind of
scandal with usa swimming
not just with respect to sean in his
relation his inappropriate relationship
with
with ariana and the kind of um
you know legal actions that took place
in the wake of that
but also more broadly about how usa
swimming
deals with these sorts of situations
historically
yeah so you get these weird text
messages you know in them you rep
you respond and you're like this isn't
funny you know blah blah blah and you
reported at the time right so is this
like 2011 2010
201 the beginning of 11
or the middle of 10. and what does usa
swimming
say to you so i turned them in
and admittedly you know following my
classic caroline pattern
my first message to them was please just
do what you need to do and leave me out
of this
i don't want to make anybody upset and
that was my
first reaction but being the people
pleaser that you are
i suspect it was even a struggle for you
to
decide to report them to begin with very
very difficult
despite it being so highly inappropriate
um aaron actually was the one that
encouraged me to
to do it you know he's a very he's an
advocate for
like what's right in usa swimming and
he's he's been fantastic with that
um and so i said okay okay look i'll do
it
i don't want to upset anybody so i
turned them in
and you know i remember
them asking me if i wanted to appear on
a call so i appeared on a call
sean didn't show bob did show and he was
apologetic and you know the whole thing
um
and that was that there was never
anything else done about it
and that i think bob bowman gets named
to be
an olympic coach right
and so nothing happens to bob bowman at
all except
maybe some stern words from frank bush
and that's kind of it
yeah that was it and of course i was so
um
i don't know if the word traumatized is
correct but it's really the only word
that comes up for me
that i just was like sure you guys do it
you know i i just want to stay out of it
please just
leave me out of it i didn't feel i had a
voice to even
insert myself into this situation and
share how i felt and what my thoughts
were and what my feelings were
um and i i
[Music]
since have felt more empowered
um to talk about that and how it's
absolutely not okay
and it just shouldn't happen across the
board but
man did i just not feel like i had any
voice in that
at all there was no and when you raised
your voice it didn't seem like it had
any
impact i mean sean ended up paying a a
you know a greater price for
for good reason but none of this was
reported
until 2018. so you do this
and then it's all kind of dealt with
behind the scenes
eight years on one level or another
until 2018 when
the oc register of all publications
uh you know does this deep dive
investigative
journalism into this story and the story
breaks in this local paper and then it
becomes like a national story
yeah and that rocked me like
that rocked me because i had never um
i'd ran away from it i ran away from
everything for those eight years
every single thing that occurred in my
life that
was not okay from you know a coach or a
relationship or
you know basically those two things um
i ran away from it all because i didn't
know how to
address it a sheepish i didn't i didn't
know how to even say anything i
it wasn't a big deal to to speak up then
either
people don't do that people never really
did that you know women didn't really
speak up i mean
ali raisman sort of put that on the map
right where you're just like
this isn't okay like i'm gonna stand up
for what's right and
and you you can't be speaking like this
to young women and i understood that i
was
23 you know and then i was a little bit
older and i was retired quote unquote
but the
the idea is that these things shouldn't
be happening at all because if they're
thinking it then
it was being thought when i was a
swimmer and being you know
not just because it wasn't acted on then
doesn't mean it's still okay
um and so and nothing happened
until 2018 and um
that was when they dug up all that stuff
for ariana's case and they called me
and you know they were like did this
happen to you
and i'm like yeah of course i turned in
the information like
what's going on i was startled totally
like what's going on
well this is so and so i need to know
this because you're under investigation
because we found
files from sean toward you
and i was just in that moment
rich like my whole being shut down
because my body in fight-or-flight was
just like yeah
oh my god like you're you're gonna die
like that was how i reacted and i was
just literally on
my apartment my like second apartment in
la
my floor for a straight week i don't
think i ate one meal
i was on the phone with jack every day
like all day i don't think i
drank any water i don't think i went out
of my apartment i was ordering in
anything i needed like i i didn't want
to be seen it was all of a sudden like
i was the bad guy that was my view of it
is that i was now the bad guy
and i oh because bowman's this huge hero
too yeah and i respected him as a coach
i really
really did and i you know i didn't have
any that was a shock from him i didn't
have any problems
with bob you know so that was a shock
from him from sean no
you know but yeah and for people that
are listening i mean sean
it turns out had had you know developed
a highly inappropriate relationship with
ariana dating back to beginning when she
was 13
years old like grooming her sexually
assaulting her at
16 i believe ultimately getting
banned from the sport i think they just
settled the civil
lawsuit um i don't know if there's any
update on
what's going on with that guy but he's
not answering anymore
yeah but short of that story coming out
in 2018
this was all being dealt with
surreptitiously which is kind of par for
the course for usa swimming that
time and time again has to weather these
scandals and you would think they would
learn their lesson
and figure out a way to deal with this
stuff above board but
they seem to continue to trip on
themselves and
handle it miserably and it's it's really
reprehensible and inexplicable i mean i
guess i can understand these people who
are
trying to cover their ass and you know
keep these things from being
public scandals but they consistently
seem to do the wrong thing here and this
dates back
decades and i don't i think we've talked
about this i don't know if you know this
but
but my high school girlfriend was kelly
davies and she was
sexually harassed by our swim coach rick
curl that was going on well i was in a
relationship with her this is like back
in the
you know like the early mid 80s
and you know it was a very different
time back then
that was settled privately
for like 150 000 back in like 1988 or
86 or something like that and resurfaced
many years later
because kelly for reasons that i'm sure
you can relate to
had a lot of unresolved trauma over this
and when she
saw rick curl when she turned on the
television to watch olympic trials on
the deck
and it occurred to her like this guy's
still coaching and
nobody knows what happened because this
was dealt with in the way that it was
dealt with
it became an intolerable situation and
you know she alerted usa swimming i
don't think that they dealt with it as
well as they
should have at the time ultimately it
all came to light
because the washington post like the oc
register
cottoned onto the story and decided to
you know pull on a few threads
and expose the whole thing which
ultimately led to rick curl
going to jail but this was so
long after the fact yeah right
and it was something that i'm sure usa
swimming thought was in the past
and you know these things you know
tend to not go away unless they're dealt
with swiftly
and responsibly yeah what you don't deal
with
will always come back you know and
across the board it always comes back
full circle like things that aren't
dealt with
whether it's personally or within an
organization or whatever it is it's
gonna come back around
it's not just gone and uh
i think i always had a feeling it would
i just didn't know when
you know i always like i always felt
like how is this
it like this can't really that can't be
it right
like something has to to come to the
surface with this even if it's just
bylaws and different things that come
out that are you know governing the
whole
coaching body as you know usa swimming
coaching body as a whole like what do
they need to do in order to
pass certain ethical right standards
well they seem to kind of adhere to the
letter of the law but not the spirit of
the law like they have the hotline you
can call if something
happens and you can report it but in the
case of
of sean didn't the usa swimming's
general counsel like appointed this
former fbi
investigator to do the sort of
you know roll up your sleeves work and
interview all these witnesses but they
ended
up shutting her down and in the case of
hutchinson
she was deprived of being able to
interview certain critical people
including like territories right in this
situation so the true story
is never fully documented for the public
record
yeah and there's just i i had to commute
to long beach multiple
times to do different things with
lawyers and all this
i just just and i felt like how is this
uh how's this ever gonna be okay there's
so many layers to this like so many
people have these stories and these
things about multiple people
and in usa swimming and in usa
gymnastics and you know in all these
sports and these ngbs it's like there's
so much of this going on
there's also great coaches i mean my
club coach oh my gosh this gave me up
most
respect for him but there's something's
got to change
and it's you know as we talk about with
everything it's got to kind of wipe the
system clean and start over
and that's the hard part is where do you
even how do you even do that when
there's been legends
floating around forever but you know
back to what you were saying about
people just try and cover things up
i think everybody was just afraid to
upset someone else who's afraid to upset
someone else who's afraid to upset
someone else so everything just got
swept up right
and then there's you who doesn't want to
upset anybody either so you've
suffered the trauma of having you know
been in the middle of that experience
itself and then there's the trauma of
now this is public and i'm a
people-pleasing person who doesn't want
to rock the boat and wants to be
well-liked yeah and now
all this attention is being directed at
me right
and you know it's not just the text
messages
it's there's other stuff that goes on
that people don't know you know comments
on pool deck
and little emails here and there and you
know it's like all different things
throughout my career that i had to
not only dig up and turn in but
say out loud and that in itself
is like a whole trauma re-experience you
know that whole thing was just
really flooded me and this was like what
two years ago
three years ago two two two march of
gosh it feels like 2018 i think yeah um
but the act of actually becoming aware
you know
it's kind of interesting the awareness
piece in sport
is huge right like you hear gervais talk
about like awareness is everything
because i was so aware and then i pushed
it down
when i became aware again and everything
rose to the surface
it was like oh [ __ ] my whole world was
just like
holy crap right because you hadn't you
hadn't done anything to heal from any of
that you've just been compartmentalizing
it
compartmentalizing it um coping
all my coping strategies with food and
with
exercise and i became so obsessed with
these other things
in order to feel like i could run from
the things that had really hurt me that
started with this pattern way long ago
and just carried on throughout my life
it's like not these little symptoms of
things right it's like this underlying
thing
that i just couldn't speak up about or i
was afraid to
you know hurt people's feelings so i
never did any of these things
and um when all that was unpacked and my
awareness was so high
and my senses were out and i was so in
tune with what was going on and holy
crap this is a big deal
caroline like you've been pushing down a
lot of stuff
that was like a whole tornado of things
in my life it felt like my whole
i felt like my life was ending to be
honest like at that time in 2018 i was
like
i've been essentially abused for a
really long time and i haven't even been
able
to say that and you know i don't and i'm
not trying to laugh at that but i'm just
um of course i'm not but i get so shy
saying that because i i'm
very sheepish at the fact that i didn't
see that
yeah that i didn't i wasn't aware of how
not okay that was i thought it was
normal to be given comments on pool deck
by a coach i thought it was normal
to be sent secret emails i thought it
was normal to have text message you know
i thought that stuff was normal it means
they liked me
right and that's and this is what it
took for you to confront that so on some
level as
painful and as uncomfortable as it must
have been when all of this
you know was revealed in the way that it
was this compelled you to face these
certain things and
and and wrestle with them so that you
could ultimately heal
yeah something had to crack but what's
interesting is
and i think we talked about this around
this time
because we had some communication when
these articles came out
yeah um i was i was confused because
although it was picked up by the media
it went from the oc register i mean
sports illustrated espn
wrote about it this was also kind of
right in the thick of
ronan farrow me too stuff as well
and i thought this was going to blow up
much bigger than it actually did
most people aren't even aware of that so
did i it kind of went away
so did i and i think there's so much
that has happened in the swimming world
that
hasn't even come to the surface that
could um i did too
i did too and i think the anticipation
of that was terrifying
because being exposed like that is
there's nothing
worse there's nothing worse in the world
than opening up cnn and seeing your name
on the
first headline i mean i was sitting
in my apartment on the floor just like
in total shock like what did i do wrong
and that was that was where my brain was
at but you must be getting calls and
texts from
friends and getting a lot of support
from people tons of support
a ton like i mean through the roof
letters emails this whole thing but at
the same time where i was at
was still what did you do wrong caroline
people aren't going to like you here
you're going to lose you know
your friends will be gone like oh no
michael doesn't know what to say he
you're going to lose his friendship or
allison or you know these people that
were under bob and all this and i just
felt so
paranoid that i would be able to have a
relationship with swimming again
that it can't you're not going to be
able to show up on the pool deck at
olympic trials to support your brother
and that was everything like that that
feeling that i was losing my world
and even though i had ran away from that
world i was losing my world yet i had
been running away from it for eight
years so i don't know why i thought i
was losing it but to me
i and i still like honestly full
disclosure full vulnerable
vulnerability here i still have some
days where i'm like
huh i wonder what they would think of me
if i just saw them
at the airport or like would things be
okay
yet like would things be normal if i ran
into
you know some of my friends or whatever
that i seemingly thought in my mind or
mad at me even though i know for a fact
they're not
yeah um but again that
pattern and why is it that's ingrained
in me that like i've upset
you know the men in power and that was
like
that was the thing for me was like these
men and pal like i didn't want bob to be
upset with me
right that was all i was telling jack
that was literally all i was telling
jack was i just don't want bob to be
upset with me and he was like he's not
upset with you
what did jack see yeah what did jack
jack's so supportive he's not upset with
you you
know this isn't a bob issue this is a
sean issue like this isn't you know
also like this isn't okay
right you know so like this isn't about
that mm-hmm and like gearing me back
toward away from my pattern and toward
the tree
also like who cares right and
like honestly though and like i remember
being
like when i got to that point it was a
very much a freeing feeling
because i get so proud of how far i've
come
in two years from that moment but i'm i
can take myself back to that feeling and
it's just
so intense of how
how much people pleasing played a role
in justice and truth like my truth was
tainted by
people pleasing and your default uh
setting to kind of defer to men in power
yeah that was awesome so i want to i
want to talk about
the two years since because you've done
a lot of work
yeah to put yourself back together so i
want to get an understanding of
how you began that process and what it
looked like for you
yeah because i think this is olympics
aside
like i think this is the the piece that
so many people
are going to be able to relate to yeah
this is the meat and potatoes i guess
you could say the uh
most important part about what i um
went through was asking for help i
finally asked for help
and i had been in and out of therapy for
years
you know leading up to all this in 2018
but it was coping it was i learned how
to cope
really well um
i started to recognize right around the
time that this stuff came out in the
news
that my body was telling me something
right so i hadn't had a period in 10
years
10 years maybe more not one
like nothing so as a woman 2000 2008 to
yeah as a woman you're yes exactly that
long
yes so your entire career my entire
post olympic career and i i had like
very irregular hormones throughout my
career as well like very sporadic
but the feeling as a woman of n nothing
vibrating through your body like no
uh hormones and you're you're just flat
i was in complete dorsal state
for this entire time nothing i couldn't
cry i could you know i couldn't cry at
all i was like
barely emotional unless it was something
gigantic but you know something would
happen i wouldn't cry i was just
flat i was i was kind of like dead in a
way
inside um and you know
my body was very unhealthy i
had disordered eating i wasn't eating i
was doing different things that were not
healthy
with my nutrition at all and
my body started to break so
as we know i i broke my heel
right before otillo rich and i were
going to go uh head on over
ron o'tillo and i uh or uttalu however
every time i do that though i get a
bunch of messages from
from people in sweden who are angry that
i got it wrong so i
don't even try it's something
let's just say
so but we're just going to be ugly
americans and call it we're just going
to be ugly americans
yeah so yeah you were going to do it and
then you
me and health went up to yeah to donner
like to train
and you texted me like the day that you
were going gonna go and you said please
come
come out let's just do this and i'm like
but my heel's broken i'm a mess this
thing just happened like what do i do i
know but like you need to come anyway
and you were like i don't think you
understand how god sent
you were for me at that moment it was
like
somebody believed in me even though i
was like on the ground
lit literally on the ground crying for
you know
i didn't know i didn't tell anybody yeah
i didn't show it i mean i knew you were
going through stuff but i just liked
your energy and i wanted you around
yeah i i and i and i loved you guys so i
was like
sure i'm there so i go up there with my
broken heel
um and that was the first sign right
that something was off
but to me it's just an injury get
through it boom maybe you can
go whatever so we'd ended up going to
that race i didn't do it hillary ends up
being pregnant so it was all a wash
anyways
it's perfect she was relieved when i
told her she was like wait i'm pregnant
i was like
okay great so we are on the same page
here
um so i
healed up from that the moment i healed
up from that
i got septic knee in my right knee
from the ocean getting in after it
rained i was in the hospital for three
four days
you know the whole thing went into my
body the body was just saying [ __ ] you
it was pissed yes like you've been
running
why are you still running like let's you
know let's do something
so like i'm throwing all this stuff at
you
emotionally but you're still
operating as if everything's normal so
i'm gonna i need to literally cut you
off at the knees in order for you to pay
attention
and did literally that yeah and then the
moment i get back from my
my knee i get my broke my heel again
and at that point i was like holy [ __ ] i
think i get this
and it was this light bulb that went off
that was like okay remember your career
caroline when
you finally realize the mind-body
connection and you realize that you
couldn't train that way
if you needed to be you know here and so
you pivoted and you did this
that's what's happening your body is
over trained and telling you something
you know
simplest terms at that point so what's
going on
let's heal it so the second heal comes
around dr batten who's down the street
here he's amazing he's
our olympic ortho he works for the
dodgers he looked at me and he was like
you need to stop right now 14 weeks on
crutches and i was like no
i thought my life was over so 14 weeks
or whatever the second time
and i finally healed i got my periods
back
um i had started acupuncture
and i started somatic experiencing
therapy all during this time so
what is that tell me what that is so it
focuses on the nervous system
so the basically it's not talk therapy
so it's not just cognitive behavioral
therapy it does like
rapid eye movement work kind of takes
you back into experiences of your life
and you kind of heal them through
going back into them and working through
them it's nasty at first
it's nasty but you work you do the
nervous system like it's through your
nervous system
breathing and meditation work but you're
working with somebody this whole time so
it's not just talking and then leaving
you know which works but you know i
think that's fantastic for whoever's
choosing to do that but for me
personally as a feeler
you know as i've explained here it's
like i feel
my body feels its way through
performance it feels its way through
everything i've done it's shown me first
before my head has
and so it changed my life because i was
able to repair the trauma that was going
on in my system
i mean it took a year for me
to get to a point where i wasn't having
nightmares and flashbacks in the middle
of the night
it was brutal like um
but so during that time i started all of
that so it was like the
in conjunction with healing myself you
know on crutches
i was able to sit still and work on what
i needed to work on
internally and
it was so it was so eye-opening to me to
realize that
i was finally in alignment
with what i do best and that's working
through my feeling
and through my nervous system instead of
just trying to solve it all here
and think about it right and
intellectualize it you gotta put
pictures of bananas in your locker
yes right get back to that i need to get
back to that
that's what works for you that is what
works and i had been
going against what worked for me for so
long
trying to intellectualize change and
create all these thought processes that
like
you know i'd listen to all these things
and read all these books and whatever
and try and do everything that i was
told nothing was working for me
because i wasn't getting to know myself
and what worked for me i wasn't diving
into me
i can read all the books i want i can do
all the things i need to do
but if i'm not choosing my body and my
system
i'm not actually healing and this topic
i'm
so passionate about but um
so then there's a little caveat here so
then i i get a concussion
[Laughter]
so i'm giving blood i leave the facility
this corner of this table right here
it's like a cement table
i'm almost six frame and five ten just
collapse leaning tower of pisa straight
to the side nail my head on the
side of the um concrete table
hit the floor ricochets back hits it
again
staples stitches crack my skull open you
just i don't get it you slipped
no i just painted it you painted it
painted you couldn't notice yeah
but it was like a straight to the side
kind of deal not just like a collapse
kind of deal
it was like a boom as hard as possible
so luckily i was
one minute from the er at that facility
so
i went over there why did you faint
though i guess i can't give blood i
guess it's just okay oh
that's right you were given blood okay
you can't do that i guess yeah
so um which is a bummer because i was
really excited about that
all right anyway so you're you're
so basically what i gather from this the
universe is like
okay you're starting to pay attention
but like we need to go a little bit
deeper deeper so i'm gonna
i'm gonna literally knock you out yes
and that moment
really did it woke me up in a very harsh
way
so i hit my head and i've never
understood a brain trauma until that you
know i don't understand
um what happens with a brain trauma
nobody does until you go through it
you can see people with tbi you can see
them go through concussion football
players like people you know
and how like glossed over they are how
you can't have a conversation with them
they
they appear quote unquote stupid or slow
that is real
i couldn't carry us i couldn't string a
sentence together oh whoa
i couldn't have a conversation like if
you and i were sitting right here i
couldn't last for five minutes i would
have gotten out and left
2019 uh
i had no idea about those in the yeah
like right christmas
wow uh 18 sorry at christmas so like
well i'm talking all this happened
within right this is not two months ago
yeah
no so that took me until like july
to heal like a whole year this is about
a year and a half ago that i felt healed
for the most part um and so that was
like a whole
thing where i you know i i was just
i was really working through what this
tbi was like i couldn't associate with
things i couldn't really understand what
was going on
and then when i started to heal i
started to see things differently i was
like holy [ __ ]
like i have a lot to unpack it was
literally like i got hit over the head
and it woke me up to different things
that i had started but that still needed
to be
dug a little bit deeper so we dug up
another layer
and we go a little deeper and then you
say we what does that look like
like working with a with a therapist
yeah so sarah
baldwin is the woman i had been working
with and so you know that kind of sets
you back
and then you have to dive back into
things and kind of peel up
what has happened for you because
actually when you do get hit in the head
your brain actually does bring it does
rough ruffle things around brings things
up that have been
varied which is terrifying like so you
had like weird memories that
uh-huh weird dreams we're coming back up
again
weird memories um and so that sort of
healed up
there and then as i'm
kind of getting back into the somatic
experiencing at that point
which was exactly a year and a half ago
now
um all of the sudden
and i kid you not like this this and
this happened for a reason it was the
most
beautiful experience all of my trauma
came back like everything everything
came back to my dreams at night like
i was waking up with i was waking up in
panics and sweats
and i don't know if you've ever
experienced some of that like ptsd
you know post-traumatic stress kind of
feeling where you just
you feel like you're in it again mm-hmm
right
right like you you rebooted your
operating system
you get this head injury and you gotta
you know shut it down and reboot
and those memories which were you know
maybe in the
you know some subfolder deep on the hard
drive or suddenly on the desktop
like staring at you totally that's a
good way to put it
um so
i i started to to finally understand
okay so now that i've done the prep
course
for the healing with with sarah i've
i've done the prep course
done my prereqs uh
holy [ __ ] now i gotta like go to grad
school for this and it's gonna be really
hard and that was
um a really really difficult time
actually um so difficult in a different
way
not difficult because i'm going through
anything particular not difficult
because it's
present moment difficult because i'm
reliving everything again in order to
heal it
because i hadn't and i had been pushing
it down
and um it has been
incredible like truly incredible for me
to go through this experience because it
has felt like
um i'm able to
see things actually feel things
which as painful as it can be as a
feeler to feel it again
with a different perspective at a
different chapter of your life
you're able to understand
that that's not okay and that that comes
from somewhere
and that pattern is there and then you
can really you know work through that
go through that process unpack that and
kind of move on as they come up
and it took me a year like i said to not
have dreams
and nightmares and panic attacks in the
middle of the night like i'd be calling
i called the hotline on more than one
occasion last summer
every other night for months wow
because i thought i your body is in that
place again
you think you are going to die like
that's what you your brain is telling
you that when you are in a traumatic
state
you don't think with a certain part of
your brain at all you just think what do
i need to do to survive right now
and i was experiencing it as if it's
happening
in the moment right and you learn all
sorts of tools
you know to move through that but it
would wipe me out for days
and this is when i didn't talk to
anybody and this is when
i sort of went missing like i just i hid
the whole year of 2019.
most of end of 18 in 2019 i didn't
everything i did was just to make sure
that people knew i was
fine still breathing yeah so
that process of of you know on some
level reliving those experiences or
just you know emotionally confronting
them i mean that's
required if you're gonna heal right like
you've gotta walk through that process
so what was the
methodology or the technique like was it
as specific like is it
behavioral cognitive therapy or what
kind of
vein you know were you exploring this in
so it's called somatic experiencing
essie and peter levine started i don't
know if you've ever heard of
peter levine i feel like you would love
this field
by the way if you kind of dive into some
of the sc stuff and
and more of the um well i had i had
andrew huberman in here talking about
some of the you know techniques that
they use like but you know with the way
that you move your
eye movement and stuff like that and how
that helps you rewire some of your neuro
chemistry
exactly so you're basically rewiring
your entire nervous system
to think and to feel something different
that you haven't ever
felt before and your body is going to
want to not do it
you know you're not going to want to do
it so half the time
we have to stop and start over but it's
a lot of rapid eye movement stuff it's a
lot of
um like would you like ventral things
where you're like holding different
parts of your body
you recount you you say the event again
out loud and
she like take notes on what parts of
your body were tensing during that
process
so that you can then realize what parts
of your body are holding on to that
trauma
and then you do work on like releasing
that area and letting that
go because that's real i mean it's
stored in
specific parts of our body mine are hips
and feet and
like lower extremities so um
so that's a big part of it also just
essentially
um like i did a lot of
uh like actual active work so when i
would go in with sarah
i would stay on the opposite side of the
room she would stay on the opposite side
of the room
i would walk a little bit closer and she
would do certain things to like
come toward me or act a certain way and
whatever happened i would have to stop
and explain what
that what showed up for me in that
moment or like what happened oh wow
and it's i mean there's days when i
would just be like
like just sobbing my eyes out but like
the whole point of this
is to let your system get rid of it
so that you can then create space for it
to rewire so you have to start by like
sweeping like getting rid of it bringing
it up letting it out
and then rewiring it and so now i'm like
i see here like once a month it's you
know so we've really weaned down but you
know we're
rewiring that at your peak how often
were you having these sessions
three days a week oh really yeah
i was like well i'm either going to pay
for it now or pay for it later so
i'm i'm sick of running i was sick of my
own [ __ ] i was sick of getting
injured i was sick of
make seeing all these symptoms pop up
when really the issue was that i
hadn't chosen to heal myself i had
chosen to run
i had chosen to continue to follow the
same pattern i did since i was a little
girl and it's just
where can i run what can i do to just
not be seen and just make everybody
happy and do all these things like no i
need to choose myself
for the first time in a really long time
and i can't make excuses anymore
i can't just be like this happened to me
it's like no
it's not it's not working for me anymore
it's super powerful and i
i love how basically you know your life
directed you towards this by
stripping you down right this was your
divine moment like you were being
compelled
to confront this one way or the other
and had you continued to be in denial or
refused to
engage with this you know some kind of
therapeutic process
your life was going to continue to
decline like your body was going to
continue to break down it just was a
matter of how much
pain are you willing to sit with before
you're actually gonna engage with this
and like
grapple with these issues and here's the
thing is
as women as men as well that you pass on
everything that you have not healed your
system and your cells
actually hold trauma and they will
actually continue to carry that on
i don't want to have children and pass
that on to them i don't want to be
harboring resentment
and anger and you know
all of it and pass it on to the next
generation i don't want to do that
you know so i sort of view my purpose in
life as
as being able to heal so the next
generations can continue
to heal regardless of if i have my own
children or not like that's my whole
mission
is how can you create space for people
to know
that they're able to be whatever they
can be if they can really work on
healing their mind and their body
together
it's possible it's just weird for people
to understand it first it's it's not
you know it's nuanced it's it's yeah
it's not well
it gives it gives the work that you do
so much more resonance now like with
rise athletes and the
the you know these young athletes that
that you and and
and rebecca are mentoring now that
you've you know undergone this
experience like there's so much more
depth to what you can
convey yeah in these relationships and
everything has started to make sense
you know it's all been the same thing
it's just shown up in all of these
different ways in different places which
i think if we look at our lives and we
see a thread
tied through them it's usually that
thread is one thing that
everything keeps mirroring whatever it
is
in one way or in one direction or
another you know so for mine it was this
people-pleasing thing
that needed to be fixed but then as it
started to heal
it's this mind-body thing where okay
your whole life has been surrounded
about being a feeler
so now let's use that to your advantage
instead of using it as
you can only please people let's use it
as a way to be in this world as a way to
change and make change you know
what a relief what and it finally all
made sense i was like i'm not weird i'm
not weird it's just
it's just who i am and that's okay and i
don't need to apologize for it anymore
and what a gift that your body broke
down or that you
you know had the traumas that you had so
that you were given the opportunity to
confront this because
short of that you can live your whole
life kind of
uh you know babysitting these character
defects on the back burner
but nothing severe enough ever happens
that compels you to look at it
to the deep extent to which you have so
ultimately you become this stronger
better person
because of your pain yeah and i've had
some people ask me things like
well what if nothing's really happened
to me to where
it's like allowed me to see certain
things you know it's like i know they're
there but nothing's really happened to
push me into that place that's like
really bad to where i need to figure
this out
and it's a great question and i don't
necessarily know that it has to be that
way i think
what makes it easier it makes it way
easier the thing people ask
me that question i'm like i don't know
what to tell you because like i just was
in so much pain i didn't feel like i had
any other choice
that choice is available to all of us at
any moment
it's just harder to make that choice
yeah when you're not suffering
yeah because who wants to do that kind
of work suffering really does lead you
if you feel like you don't need to it's
like i got [ __ ] to do right
you'll continue to right and and so
i guess the only thing that i could
really think to say to someone in that
position is like
you know maybe
you're just trying to think about it too
much
and you really have to see what your
body is telling you
because our bodies are actually giving
us so much information
that we completely ignore and you're an
expert at this you know
well but athletes of all people are
so much more integrated in that regard
like they've been trained to pay
attention to their body and the signals
that their body is giving them so to the
extent that you are still
refusing to pay attention to that i
think you know
is powerful but the greater point being
that most people
aren't as connected to their bodies in
the way that athletes are so when their
bodies are sending them those signals
those signals are muted or
unhearable because they're you know
clouded underneath you know layers of
whatever else is going
on with that person where they're
they're just disconnected
from yeah that signal and i guess the
question is how do you
teach somebody that's disconnected from
their body how to become connected to
their body
there's a ton of modalities but i think
the real
truth to that question is getting to
know them and what actually
what their learning style is so that you
can like place one of those to it
because i think there's different places
everybody can start some people start in
meditation some people start by changing
diet some people start by movement some
people you know so it's
some people need spreadsheets and other
people need pictures of bananas yes
exactly there's so many ways to do this
no one way but yeah i think that that's
that's something i'm sort of exploring
now a lot of people ask me that how well
i'm not in tune with my body so how am i
supposed to feel this somatic experience
or whatever if i don't even
like i don't feel anything how has the
last
two years changed how you how you mentor
these young athletes
i love that question i think we've
incorporated a lot more visualization
and imagery work and breath work into
our program which is huge
um you know truth be told rebecca and i
only work with two now
each because of we have like 35 mentors
so we sort of have to run the business
side of it instead of you know just
mentoring
but my specific athletes uh it's changed
and that we have conversations about
what's showing up in their body and
they're able to
every time they do it they get better
and better at first it's like i don't
know i'm sore
i don't know my right shoulder's kind of
sore from 700 butterfly i did yesterday
and um now it's more well i was really
short of breath yesterday because i was
super stressed because i had a fight
with my boyfriend or you know i
i and i noticed i stopped breathing so
it's like cool cue
and we work on that and then they take
that and they apply it to to their
competition and to school it's
you know it's against the thing that
runs across like how can that
work in multiple environments um
but it has increased awareness it's
increased awareness for all of our
mentors the mind body
aspect in general like knowing that
working on an athlete's mind isn't it
you have to really work on
what they feel in their body what's
showing up and how to
speak to their body in a way that they
can not only become more aware of it
know what it needs but
in a way that they can create worth
through their actual being
so that it is aligned with their mind
and they find that happening together
and
and things start to click it's like oh i
feel less tense or i felt really relaxed
going into that race
what did that feel like oh my shoulders
were down and i felt like i could
breathe and
you know i felt you know so they're
they're recognizing what's happening in
their system
which if we're going to change
generations in sport you can't just
tell them to think about things you know
i mean sure
you can but in my personal
opinion and experience i've never seen
an athlete
even if they love spreadsheets and love
splits and times like my brother
not be able to tune into their body yeah
in a time when they need to and
understand what's going on what it's
telling them what information that's
giving them
and to be able to do that under pressure
or in a high stress environment where
you know your thinking brain
isn't going to cut it yeah you have to
yeah because your body's gonna tell you
first what's going on
always and that's the crazy thing is if
we listen close enough
and if we put in the reps everything is
reps wraps wraps wraps like
you just gotta keep putting in the reps
before you realize it but if you listen
close enough you're like
oh i'm super jittery like before this
race or i i
um my stomach hurts my
you know rib hurts you know all these
things that will give you information
well why do those things hurt what are
you holding on to
you know a lot of swimmers stomachs hurt
a lot of performers always claim you
know they'll throw up before races their
stomach or you know
those things are telling you something
it's information right it's not bad it's
just information
it's it's difficult to figure out what's
meaningful out of that too because as
you know
you're used to beating your body up for
so long during training and then you go
into this taper phase
right and then you're just hyper aware
of every little
niggle in your body and you're like
there's something wrong because you know
i i my toe hurts or something it's you
know and you gotta just be like no
you're just nervous
right there's nothing wrong with you
you're just hyper aware you're being
hyper vigilant because you've put so
much time
into preparing for this very specific
moment
and everything in your in your world in
your experience is super heightened
so true because the amount of times i
was told
don't pay attention how you feel or
don't worry about it if you hurt or you
know
don't think about it don't think about
how you feel and it
is so foreign to me i was like what do
you mean that's all i do is i feel i
don't understand like how am i not
supposed to think about how i feel uh
but i i you nailed it with that is it
you become so hyper aware that how can
you reframe whatever it is that you're
feeling in your system
as an okay thing as something that's
just giving you information
accepting it the practice of acceptance
if you're at a race or whatever and your
right knee hurts but you're behind the
blocks well not a lot you can do now
so reps of doing that in practice reps
of doing that with
you know a sports psych consultant reps
of doing that with your coach like what
is it that that means
how can i reframe whatever it is in that
moment through injury or through
pain that i can then use
toward whatever i need to get done and
then address it after if it's something
serious you know when it comes like
injury and whatnot
but um yeah that whole field of injury
psychology is really cool
you should pick jervae's brain on that
sometimes yeah i've never i've never
spoken about that specifically with it's
a whole deal it's for sure
it's really interesting like when i was
in grad school you guys hang out
do you hang out we used to work out
together and then he started a different
gym routine
oh he did he came to my gym oh we did we
were
buddies i see him you know at source
cafe every now and then
yeah you guys are like neighbors down
there yeah he's great i love durbay
he's we've always just had like a great
rapport
um but yeah that field is really cool
well i want to talk about your
relationship to sport now because
you know look if you scroll through your
instagram like you're you know you're
getting after it
whether it's crossfit or like swimming
in the ocean like
you st you still have this profound love
for
for movement and fitness but
what's interesting is that it's
completely outside of any competitive
context right like i almost feel like
like it was a blessing that you didn't
go and do
otillo because you're not supposed to be
your relationship to sport isn't
supposed to be about competition even if
you could have done that
from a healthy perspective of not really
caring like you know about
how well you did and just enjoying the
experience i think there's something
beautiful
and instructive about how you've
completely reframed
your relationship to sports so that it
has nothing to do
with any metric other than like joy
exactly uh so it's interesting i started
to want to be a student of different
things
i i'm very curious i wanted to try
different things because after i broke
my heels i couldn't really
do endurance things like run and whatnot
like i used to to me that was what
i needed to get done right when i
retired right run run run run run
keep running and i love running but i
was like you know let's see what's
possible let's see what's possible with
your body and running is great as long
as you're running towards something and
not away way
yes i'm just yes i'm so obsessed with
this running isn't awesome for running
away from stuff
yeah running is great once you're
running away oh yeah you're just fast as
hell yeah
um so i started getting curious
and i started thinking okay caroline you
did the same thing
for ever let's see what's possible
and let's test the the boundaries a
little bit and see
what your body can handle what it can't
learn a little bit more about what your
adrenals and kidneys can handle learn a
bit about what they can't
so i started taking courses at the gym i
took a strength 101 course i took a
strong man course
i took um a weightlifting course
i started swimming in the ocean
um what else have i done i think that's
pretty much it
mainly to strengthen conditioning but
those three courses are like eight to
ten weeks long each
so over a span of two years i took these
courses was one of those
what's that crossfit gym in venice deuce
that's where i belong
right yeah yeah yeah so they actually
have a two of three gyms one in venice
one in
hermosa and one in hollywood and so i
was i'm at the hermosa one
and um i loved it because all of a
sudden i entered back into like
eight-year-old caroline and it was like
everything's new
i can do whatever i can learn things i
don't have to be
um like a veteran at this and like you
know i can just start over again with
everything and feel
new and learn and i became so obsessed
with learning
i loved it so much that i felt like a
little kid again a student and
throughout i remember just being so sad
week eight graduation day of these
courses because i was just
just now getting started of i get this
this is a new skill
and i love learning new skills and i
love being able to see what my body can
handle
and so throughout this process i have
quickly learned that
strength strict strength is not my jam
uh my body is not built to just like
back power left yeah
true very traditional weightlifting you
mean yeah yeah
i love it it makes i need it but it's
not
like what i'm very good at loved
learning it though
could really pick and balances out um
but i took a strong man course
which i loved and it's exactly like
swimming movements so it's like full
body like stones and
like throwing logs around and stuff yes
like you're doing like caveman stuff
and i was just in like flipping tires
and i was just
in love with it i felt like very prime
it was a very primal feeling kind of
thing and everything is like a short
circuit
and you really only train it twice a
week that's all you need
i love that that was my favorite and i
could do that every day
different from four workouts a day yes
yes and so um about around that time
this was the second course i took around
that time i started to realize
okay caroline remember when you couldn't
train
you know more than four times a week at
florida once you got
down to the wire and understood what you
needed same thing with this don't
overthink
the fact that you only need to train two
times a week here
train two times a week do the other days
just a longer walk
something smooth some yoga you know and
i was
in the best shape of my life my body
loved it yeah i and all of a sudden it
was like
less is more feel yourself into this
you don't need to over train your
adrenals don't need to go to town
you know with all of this 20 hours a day
kind of
stuff you got to unravel all that
programming
around you know the kind of training you
were doing in college yeah and that's
what these courses served a purpose for
is it reta it taught me again how to be
an athlete and i didn't have to just be
one type of athlete
i could be multiple different versions
of myself
and learn what i needed and it was
beautiful especially was going to change
every year i'm 34 now i'm not 24. you
know
it's gonna change so then i took uh uh
a weightlifting course which was like
snatches and power cleans and
uh i really enjoyed that that did tax my
nervous system a little more for me
uh so out of out of learning these
things i really did settle on like
a couple days a week of strength
training is perfect for me the other
days
really kegs around yeah jump in the
ocean yes
like so on tuesday thursday saturdays
now i walk
uh-huh and i'm just i mean i'm like
expert power walker in south bay just
and i love it rich like i am listening
to podcasts
and music and before i know it i've
vlogged five and a half miles just
walking just
go for it hour you know come back and
i feel great and that's same with
swimming swim with
1500. don't get out of the ocean and
you're fine fifteen hundred that's
actually a lot
more you know oh that one well you but
you
i mean you look crazy strong and super
fit and happy and clearly you're on the
other side of this whole
process like with some clarity and a
lightness to you
yeah thanks i think i have a little ways
to go on finding
um i don't know finding my voice is is
the right word but i'm still learning
that it's okay to
have opinions and still learning it's
okay to
skip my mind i know i i'm still learning
it
the people pleasing thing is tough man i
suffer from that
tremendously you know it's it's not easy
you know it's it's hard to i think with
social media stuff because i feel like
who i am as a person can't be portrayed
in a square
so it's like about a rectangle yeah
i'm like what other app can i join that
feels like me you know i
i don't know it's just it's a funny
world but i'm still
waiting for my uh myself to believe in
myself a little more with
things i have to say and things that i
um
i can only hope that storytelling and
sharing experiences will allow other
people to feel empowered to do the same
because i think we
connect through experiences and through
being able to share our lives with
people so i love what you're doing with
profits walk among us like
that's exactly it that's exactly what it
is
that life is about everybody has a story
to tell and
how else are we going to get to
understand ourselves and others
it's the only way forward you know and i
think
that's why i'm such a strong believer in
conversations like this
because to the extent that your life
experiences
is vastly different from somebody who's
listening
there is a shared humanity and my hope
and my belief
is that you know the the person who
needs to connect with what you have to
say
is going to connect with it you know and
it's only by giving
a person like yourself enough bandwidth
to
share themselves openly over time that
you allow that process to occur
yeah it takes a minute to get there too
and
no shame if people aren't ready to share
their stories in their lives
i certainly wasn't right for however
many years i don't but if i was to
plop you down onto the pool deck of
olympic trials like right now
like and you had to go see all these
coaches and
all these old friends what does that
bring up for you
right now
in a weird way it's like the first word
that came to mind was peace
like i just feel okay with it you know
like i feel like
it would maybe not peace maybe
indifferent
like of course you have the what does
this person think of me based on the
the situation two years ago or you know
based on whatever
what is this but at the same time kind
of like that's their business not mine
i'm just sort of indifferent i think i i
i see myself as um
a human more than a swimmer now than
than i used to
i used to only be able to identify with
my worth in life
with that and that's why it was so
confusing
because my worth was identified as
something that i was proud of but that i
was also
like that's that's it that's not me
i don't want to be associated with that
all the time like they're you know so
yeah i think the the the confusing and
and somewhat pernicious aspect of that
is that
it's not like your parents or the
coaches or anybody is saying
you're only valuable to me to the extent
that you perform it's not like that
totally it's
it's a more ephemeral systemic thing
where
you know maybe it's not even an
expectation but it's just an environment
in which you're reared to believe that
you're more valuable if you
perform at a higher level absolutely and
you you start to
intuit that and you imbue that and then
that becomes
like this you know seed of of
destruction later yes and
just on that note i always
i always want to say that
you can have your feelings about sport
and your experiences
and also be so passionate about what
you're doing
to create change and to create something
better
for the world you know i like anybody
that goes through something
and then they become an activist in that
thing
so that they can create change but it
doesn't mean
that they're um still
angry at that and i think i'm to the
point now where i'm not angry at it
anymore
it's like i'm just in a space of like
okay you know the anger has subsided
like that was strong but now it's just
like okay
like let's do something about this
i mean that feels honest to me that
feels honest to me you know and i think
ultimately with your continued
you know uh commitment to growth
that ultimately you could land on that
pool deck and just be
excited and yeah and joyful and looking
forward to seeing these people as
opposed to indifferent
yeah and i yeah i definitely want to get
to the point where it's like
hell yeah yeah
and i would imag you know evolution is
not
you know it's not linear it's also not
instant i think a lot of people
go through you know that path of
of well um you know is this happening
now or never or do i give up or do i
keep going and
the answer is keep going you just keep
going you can't gauge the process when
you're in it anyway
100 not you can't really even see it you
know and i
i don't think that any human that sits
in this chair that talks to you has
anything figured out
nobody has anything figured out we're
all still learning
you know and and i say that with utmost
love for everybody i learn
so much from people that you know speak
on your podcast that speak on multiple
and i'm sitting here thinking
how vulnerable it is to hear from people
that are still growing
how cool is it that we can learn from
people that are still growing and still
learning
and still sharing and in five years
they're gonna have something totally
different to say
i think it's more powerful that way yeah
when somebody
you know is delivering some message from
the perspective of i've
i i have it all figured out and let me
tell you here's how you do it
i immediately tune out yeah i want to
hear you know the honest
vulnerable truth of somebody who's made
progress
but is struggling and is sharing their
experience from the heart like that's
what i'm able to connect with
yeah we're we're all sharing what we're
still processing
it's just a matter of if we're aware of
it or not
you know like we're all sharing things
we're still working through
so maybe a good way to end it is to
share a little bit or impart a little
bit of wisdom or experience to
the younger athlete who's tuning in who
perhaps is feeling like their worth is
being measured by the extent to which
they're able to perform or who feels
like
they're not able to be themselves
completely
in whatever lane they've chosen right
now and is trying to figure out how to
have a healthier relationship to
you know maybe it's sport but maybe it's
some other thing that
they're involved in well there's two
things one is that you can be
feeling it's okay to feel that way your
feelings are valid
i think that is very important for a
young athlete to feel
your feelings are valid they're not
right or wrong
they're not measured but learning how to
use them
constructively whether it's through
sharing or understanding it
communicating
and being able to use those and move
forward with whatever that is is the key
so i think we we get wrapped up in not
saying anything
because we're afraid to upset somebody
but if there's somebody that you can
share
how you feel with and that feels like a
safe space for you
it feels safe to validate your feelings
say it's okay you feel that way
let's get a little more information
about that what is it that's really
showing up there
and really understanding the the human's
heart
first they're going to be able to
perform better they're going to be able
to take that and use whatever that is
and turn it into something constructive
because i think we we get stuck
in our feelings and we get stuck just
thinking they don't matter brushing them
away
pushing them away really there's so much
power in that there's so much
information
to be had in that that's beautiful
regardless of if they're positive or
negative you can take that
re-mold it and turn it into an amazing
performance
grade on a test relationship with
somebody with your family members
um extracurricular whatever it is that
that person's wanting to do
so that's something i like to say
because i think
we're shameful of our feelings we're
shameful of what that means
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just information
and i wish i would have known that i
wish i would have been okay knowing that
however i felt was okay
and that it wasn't there was nothing
wrong with it it was just information
yeah that's beautiful i think it's super
important i feel like
at least in the context of sport there
has been a lot of progress
and movement in the right direction in
terms of better understanding
that aspect of it i mean i'm two
generations older than you
but when i see you know the way that
young athletes are being
coached and mentored now compared to
what it was like when i was a kid i mean
that was a long time ago but
you know of course much more there's
much more to be gleaned and learned
totally mental health is at the
forefront right now people are caring
about how people feel
and and
you know this is an important thing to
note is that
you can be struggling and also
be okay with your performances you can
admit
that you're having a hard time and also
you'll you'll still be okay you can
still
be and do great things i think there's
a um
a misunderstanding there that if i again
back to that
if i share that i'm depressed or having
a hard time
or uh going through something
then that means i it's gonna it's gonna
be well impinge on your performance
right i mean that's the whole message of
the weight of gold right it's like kind
of a call to action to embrace
that aspect of what it means to be
vulnerable and
and to have the courage to raise your
hand and ask for help absolutely the
shrouding of it the hiding of it because
you're supposed to be you know this
bulletproof individual
is not in service to anybody and
certainly not yourself
and it's not complaining it's owning
it's self-ownership
you know i think there's a difference
between complaining i have some athletes
say well
i don't want to complain it's if we can
shift it
to its self-ownership then we can take
that and use it
just because you're having a hard time
have asked for help et cetera doesn't
mean you're all of a sudden gonna
perform poorly
right it doesn't mean that you're not
focusing on your swimming or your
baseball or whatever it means that
you're doing something for your mental
health which will then help that
so it's a perspective shift right it
does require some level
of of mind-body integration though
because you have to know
when you are copying out like am i just
am i just wimping out here
or am i really um in jeopardy where i
need
some outside help like there is a
difference and if you don't have that
kind of
intuition then you know you might be
just
you know indulging in your laziness yeah
you know
instead of really being in peril but
that's
where great coaches and mentors come in
because if somebody is vulnerable enough
to share whatever it is
then they can catch that and be able to
change that and turn that into something
otherwise they will just sit in their
[ __ ]
so to speak and you know let it go to
[ __ ] and
well whatever i'm just copping out you
know so if they can
articulate that communicate that
information to whomever
you know coach mentor and this is where
coaches and mentors can can hear that
taking that information and being able
to help somebody being able to
to identify it without shame and turn it
into something better
call them out on what it is in a nice
way in a beautiful way like
hey you're you're tough let's make
something out of this like we're not
going to let this happen to you here
that's where things can shift for the
positive
because you're you're changing the
behavior through let's act on this
right let's move through this let's not
tell you it's wrong and just
make you sit in it longer let's let's
make some change here
you know let's do something and that's
on you you're the one athlete you're the
one that needs to make the change i'm
here to guide you
yeah well i think that responsibility
like we're kind of talking about it
from the perspective of the athlete what
their responsibility
is but that responsibility also rests on
the coach to create an environment
that's conducive and safe for that
person to do that
and i think that um
this is applicable outside of sport in
the workplace like a boss
you know employee relationship or how
management is structured so that
the work staff feels like they can you
know raise certain issues and the
manager is creating an environment
that's conducive to that i think you
know ultimately leads to a much more
effective
healthy place to work or you know
environment to excel
as an athlete absolutely and that is one
of the most important things that i
think any organization can hold
coaches teams usa swimming is that if
the standard is held there and if people
are all believing in whatever
leadership there is and the leaders are
able to develop these people
athletes you know employees whatever it
is into a space of
vulnerability openness and action
on what it is that we're doing not just
talking about it and sitting around it's
like actually acting on it
whether that action is let's sit with
this for a minute or that action is
let's take action and do something right
now
both of those things are beautiful
that's how
things develop and um
yeah those are my greatest learnings
from mike deboers he was just very much
either like okay let's now that we have
that information
let's either go this way and act on it
immediately or
i'm gonna let you sit with that for a
second i'm here right here next to you
but i'm gonna let you sit with that for
a second and like knowing that i was
like held in that space
i think you know reflecting back that
makes all the difference because either
way is an action
you're giving you're empowering them
either way right i gotta figure it out
on their own either way
but it's the person that's gonna hold
steady and sturdy there that's holding
the leadership standard
yeah that you believe in that last thing
um
were there any books that stand out that
you've read through this process of
trying to you know manage everything
that you've managed over the couple
years that you found to be
helpful yeah um well i love yours by the
way that i just got
wish i got it a long time ago i don't
know that it's gonna help anybody with
their people
pleasing no it doesn't uh but it but it
also does
uh help you feel not alone so that's
huge
um the my favorite books are
um very abstract so i like eastern body
western mind if you've read that book
um the body keeps score
huge for me um i'm actually
reading becoming supernatural right now
which i really love
uh loyalty to your soul um
i'm i read like a lot of mind body style
books to where you're integrating like
energy centers with
mindset work so it's an abstract way of
thinking
i could name all my books and sports
likes in grad school but
those are just sports likes but no i'm
thinking more in the context of
you know somebody who's dealing with
these these kind of particular emotional
things that you've
you've been dealing with and i didn't
read a book for however many years
during that i know i saw your latest
instagram post about that i didn't read
one single book
i i started reading like when i broke my
heel i started reading again
i started doing everything that i hadn't
done again to try
um but those are the books i gravitated
toward i gravitated toward
books that felt like intuitively they
were calling me
to they were i was drawn to them because
they were about the things that
i felt unseen with that i that i needed
to understand better about myself
which was that connection between the
mind and the body
in a way that wasn't uh just psychology
in sports psych in a way that was like a
very
spiritual sense that i could understand
a little bit better
yeah about myself um but there are
several others in there that i really
enjoyed throughout that time i'm
probably blanking on a lot of them
but well you can email me a list or
whatever and we'll put them up in the
show notes
i'll go through my little shelf yeah
yeah got a lot of good ones
burkle's reading list from the mind of
somebody who didn't read books for six
years
yeah it's like just sketchbooks and like
yeah right
pictures of bananas
cool so what's left like what's the
what's the thing that's tripping you up
now or like the hurdle that you're
trying to
overcome
i think the last the last part of what i
was just talking about about
uh my voice and finding what it is that
i feel um okay
to talk about it's really difficult like
i'm very comfortable with you i can talk
with you about
these things but i feel like
something that i'm really working on and
getting over is feeling
judged for how do you share your story
and what it is that i'm you know that i
stand by
without sounding like this complaining
victim or something
and i would really like to get to the
bottom of that
because it feels like i get stuck
in that space of um
so much to say and i have so much i
believe in
that i articulating it still i don't
i don't know i i wanna i wanna feel
confident in that that it's just
sharing and not making anybody feel
sorry for me or anything you know
i mean i think it's about intention yeah
what is your intention what's your
motivation
what's behind the desire to write
whatever it is you
you're going to write or say whatever it
is you're going to say yeah you know if
it's coming from a whiny place then
you know it's going to come off as com
complaining but if it's coming from
a desire to share in service to other
people who might be
experiencing those emotions then it has
a different tenor to it
i love connection if i can connect with
people
that's my number one intention i just i
love connection it's everything to me
so whenever i hear people experience
something similar or go through
something and
approach me about it or ask questions
feels like we're human together it feels
like we can
be constructive in that conversation and
not feel like it's just
a problem well you must get that with
rise though
and all these relationships with these
other yeah i definitely do and i really
enjoy that
and i've been sketching more and getting
back to my fit and roots a little bit
which i love noticed yeah i love it i
just
i i started drawing just fashion
sketches and then i was just like shoot
i'm just gonna draw the body and that
actually started helping me heal my body
i started sketching during my concussion
by the way because i couldn't formulate
words but
um that was huge wow so
that was really helpful for me in order
to connect with people because i met a
whole new community of people
in the art world and that felt really
cool to explain and share what it is
that
i'm doing through i'm healing my body
through sketching i'm healing my
my body and my mind through drawing the
body
through becoming one with my body again
that i struggled with for so long
so um that was really cool and that was
a whole new world
that opened up my eyes to connection and
that there's
a lot of a lot of worlds out there yeah
a lot of people out there there's a lot
of stuff out there that
i can open my eyes to finally well as
somebody 20 years your senior
i can tell you that there's plenty more
out there for you to learn and explore
and i can't wait to see where you
end up directing your energy well thanks
i'm excited for it
i'll probably call you up for some
advice um
that was super inspiring thank you and i
think it's i think it's gonna be really
helpful to a lot of people so i
appreciate it i adore you
uh i i want only good things for you and
i hope that you consider me a friend and
a resource
i for sure do thank you so much cool um
so if you want to connect with caroline
you can find her on instagram caro
berkel
there if you're an athlete in search of
mentorship you should check out rise
athletes rise.athletes.com
rise dash after rise that's why matt
rise dash athletes.com
which i should have said earlier is the
company that you and rebecca sony
founded
to you know be the kind of mentor to
young athletes that you wish you guys
had had when you were younger
i had rebecca on very early on in the
podcast and she shares a lot about that
so you can check out that episode as
well
yeah and your website carolineberkel.com
where you can buy art prints spruce that
up by the way
you're smoking heart prints here i don't
know i am
originals and at some point perhaps
you know tillow swim run might launch
i'm so down
i'm saying
he's great he he has such good energy
he's hysterical and he's doing his same
mission you know he went through the
same struggles
yeah he's gone through it trying to
figure out what his thing is yeah
you know yeah i i really i always
enjoyed him he got along great
he's a jokester yeah yeah cool all right
well come back and talk to me again
sometime i will i'm down
[Music]
you